[Music]
e
day two of Rapid of the 2017 Grand chess
tour in louan Belgium it was another day
full of excitement as the best players
in the world looked to rack up the
points against the competition world
champion Magnus Carlson bounced back
from yesterday's loss with two dominant
wins to finish the day tied for second I
was good to get a win now and also one
that was uh you know had some quality to
to it so I'm I'm uh optimistic uh about
the rest day one leader Wesley Soul
racked up two victories of his own as he
finished two points clear of his nearest
rals it's all about form and getting
that great form is the real mystery here
it's the last chance to score big in the
Rapids day three action coming up
[Music]
next
welcome back everyone well the city of
louan is a university town full of
restaurants and nightlife and as you can
see lots of energy and excitement every
single day well the players are going to
have to bring their energy on day three
of Rapid which has already seen its
share of Thrills and Spills well for all
the action we're going to go to the
studio with your ba Gasser and
Christian hello and welcome to day three
of the your next move liven stage of the
grand chess tour it's the third and
final day of Rapid chess and things are
building up quite dramatically I'm
International Master van kowa and it's a
great pleasure to be here in the studio
with Grandmaster yasa sarahan Jer the
pleasure is all mind and boy we've been
fed to to
an explosive chess it's just amazing
what's going on in this it's been
absolutely wild but it's it's the final
day of Rapid chest do you think things
will get calmer no I think it's going to
continue let's take a look at our
standings yes and in the lead is our
2016 tour Champion Wesley so with 10
points out of 12 tied for second our
Maxi Vash gra and Max world champion
Magnus Carlson eight points out of 12
and TI for fourth is
and an both on Seven Points the thing
that really stands out is Vador joa with
zero points he has to get on the
scoreboard and he's got to do it today
yeah he's certainly languishing in the
doldrums and format going forward well
it's our final day of Rapid chest so
this means we have three rounds left and
they will be played at 25 minutes plus a
10c delay so again not an increment and
it's the last day where a win will count
for two points and a draw will count for
one point so from tomorrow we'll start a
weekend of Blitz chess which is 18
rounds played at 5 minutes and 3 second
delay with a more traditional Point
scoring system of a win counting for one
point and a draw half a
point and uh looking at the pairings for
today so round seven honestly they're
all exciting to me truly but some of our
leaders are being matched up look at
that Anish gear versus Magnus Carlson
both players in great form Ian versus
Wes
match of the tournament leaders as well
and two players Le and have to determine
what kind of event they're going to have
that's going to be an exciting matchup
we have Bas the world rapid Champion I
can't wait for that one and uh here in
the studio as always we have our
grandmas analyst Christian
carilla thanks guys and good morning
everyone what an exciting second day of
the 2017 Grand chest tour in Len Belgium
we had on our hands yesterday but today
another combative war is coming upon us
we have Magnus Carlson who won his last
two games one brilliant strategic win
against Vladimir Kik and one brilliant
tactical win against jababa badur who is
struggling in this event but let's
compare Paris and Len and see how many
decisive results we had in both events
in Paris on the left side we see we have
30 result 30 decisive results out of 45
possible games
in here out of six rounds in Len we have
22 decisive results out of 30 Games
possible very very combative chess being
played all over the board every player
is trying to gain an edge over the
competition let's hear Maurice's
thoughts from
Len well here in Len people have just
been thrilled by watching these great
players battle it out they have
definitely gone for it in every round
and you've seen the top players playing
well I mean certainly you have an giri
who's near the top he but for one bad
game that he probably should not have
lost he was winning against the piai
other than that he's just been playing
tremendous chess he defeated demolished
aonian with brilliant opening
preparation since then has really shown
his quality looking to play well in this
event of course Magnus Carlson he's been
playing Top Flight chess as well the
only loss against the leader Wesley so
only because he over pressed but he
wanted to go for it as is his 10
so he will have to bounce back here
today as he and Anish face off and then
there's the Frenchman Maxim Vash lra
just yesterday there was a French team
following around a studio following all
around doing a documentary on him he's
feeling quite confident right now his
amazing performance in Paris he's
following that up here in this event so
look to see him playing well as these
games transpire and of course all eyes
are on Wesley so he is leading the
tournament he's the grand chest T champ
from 2016 and he is simply in great form
and a great lead horer uh racehorse when
he's leading an event he is the kind of
player that is tough to chase of course
he's got some great thoroughbreds who
are chasing him down now so we will see
whether or not they'll be able to catch
him as day three live from Louin is set
to begin thank you Mace thank you yes
and behind every great tournament we
have a great prize fund we always do yes
and uh we have our
$150,000 in total prizes and first place
in this event will uh pick well pick you
up
$375,000 second place 25,000 third place
20,000 and even 10th Place gets a nice
chunk of change with
$75,000 good pay for a good uh week's
worth of work and in this event of
course we also have the grand chess tour
$1.2 million spread over five events
with a nice bonus pool right so yeah
first place in the grand chest tour will
get will get you $100,000 bonus second
place $50,000 bonus and of course if you
if you win the this event you pick up 13
points or 12 points whether dependent on
whether you've tied tied for first or
won the event clearly so a clear first
gets 13 points but as we saw in Paris
Magnus won a tie break but only picked
up 12 grandest T points because of the
time and Wesley needs to start picking
up those points because he didn't have a
great result in Paris so he really is
motivated here to do well just much
better much much better yes yes and
Christian as we uh we're we're closing
in on our start uh who are you uh
looking at most
closely well definitely Wesley so uh
he's been playing very very consistent
precise chess his usual trademark chess
so uh we'll see if he managed to get
over that slump he had in the past
couple of tournaments and uh reached to
his uh to his usual Heights once again
so uh yes I'm definitely looking at
Wesley I hope Vladimir kumnick which is
one of my horses and one of my favorites
in terms of uh how he plays chess in
general I hope he's going to do better
than uh than up to this moment so uh
those are my uh my two players that I'm
looking forward to
see let's head to
with Maurice and Nigel
schz well I'm with a world championship
candidate Nigel short from England Nigel
you have been in these kinds of events
where you're leading a tournament and
everybody's looking to kill you what is
it like for Wesley Soul right now as he
tries to fight off these amazing these
Gladiators who really want to make sure
they catch him I think he doesn't need
to worry too much he's been playing well
if he plays with this uh consistency
that he has done so far he will win the
event so he just needs to be calm and
and steady and not worry about what the
other people are doing you should never
look over your shoulders in a situation
like this you look at the game directly
in front of you and put all your efforts
into that that said he's got Magnus
Carlson and Maxim VRA chasing him do you
think if he plays solid chess is going
to be enough or is he going to still
have to keep his foot on the gas at
least a little bit no he he he should
not be playing directly for a draw he
should just be playing chess uh like he
has been doing uh it's a big mistake to
start calculating the number of points
that you need you think ah I make a draw
here a draw here I win this game no you
don't just play each game without
thinking about the results and play it
to its natural conclusion big advice
good advice and as we hear the bells
toll here in
Belgium that's the sign that the games
are about to begin let's get back to the
action we'll be calling it live here
from living TOS for the thank you and
there we have Malcolm Payne introducing
the
prayer you can see II coming to the
stage facing facing off Wesley
so that's a key game in this uh
round Champion
magnun shaking the hand of Vladimir crck
and of course it's always a great honor
for the grand chess tour to have the
world chess champion playing here he is
again in Len please welcome Magnus
Carlson from
[Applause]
[Music]
Norway and we always look forward to
games between Magnus and this particular
opponent maybe talking who know
welcome
in Paris
nearly
run there is uh some audio issues there
but of course maash L being introduced
and as Mar Maurice mentioned earlier
he's actually being followed by a TV
crew but who's doing a
do and he's facing off
Champion against vilia yesterday master
class in attacking and uh Here Comes one
of my picks there's anybody who's got a
spare watchs could give it to me I'm
going to go find iuk he has is he's
hiding oh there he is okay wild roller
coaster he's been writing wind loss wind
loss win L blend a and of course okay
I'll pass you over to the
rapid Champion shaking hands with leavon
quick prediction guys in the game
between Anish and Magnus because that's
the big game of the round uh what do you
think is going to happen draw Mar he's
taking taking pause for breath say draw
but an exciting draw and am there off I
have Magnus whoa with the black pieces
with the black pieces okay and by the
way D4 Pawn opening by Anish and Magnus
playing Knight F6 and G6 I expect a
groomfield I expect a Grom Feld guys
yeah I'm expecting
G3 yes maybe maybe not G3 just yet maybe
Knight F3
first
okay in case of G3 I'm wondering why
nobody at the top plays C5 and goes into
the benon structures because from what I
know uh the benon structures against the
G3 variations are quite good because of
that locked Bishop on on on G2 guys
breaking news look at this Magnus
Carlson essaying straightforward kingan
defense I didn't that's sity in his uh
practice Yeah we well we saw in Paris he
was essaying the as6 semis slav and semi
slaves Assa so um yeah there's
definitely a complete change of
direction right and I'm very pleased to
see Anish Hing going with Knight C3 and
E4 instead of the usual G3 which allows
the C6 D5 complexes but this is a great
territory to see what the players have
prepared Magnus capable of playing just
about any opening or any defense has
essayed a very uh combative stance with
the Kings Indian a favorite of many
including Bobby Fisher as well as Gary
casparo yes can't help but mention uh in
this particular uh variation by the way
one of the the moves that um leavon
aronian uh really brought
into um the elite I want to say many
players have played this idea before H2
H3 what is that move all about well in a
lot of Kings Indians uh black is
aspiring for the moves E5 and F5 and the
idea behind H3 is to take a lot of that
punch
away from Black by playing this move G4
later in the game so this move H3 is
very Cy but there are so many systems to
play um what has happened by the way was
H3 played Bishop E2 the main line main
C5 was played so uh we're drifting into
completely different structures not
Knight C6 NE E5 uh not E5 or and Knight
C6 but C5 completely different structure
closer to the benoni exactly not D5 I
think Castle was played castle and was
played all right Christian what do you
have for us uh yes I want to take a look
at the game between leevon aronian and
vasil ivanchuk we see this nimzo being
played out with G3 Bishop G2 and now
very very important is going to be this
Square on e4 and the battle begins
Knight D4 Bishop D2 was played let me
see if we have some more some more moves
on the board yes we
do and after Bishop D2 F5 solidifying
the the center on e4 Queen C2 Knight Tak
C3 I'm expecting Bishop takes C3 and at
the right moment I'm going to plant the
Knight on E5 very powerful Square I'm
going to uh exchange the light Square
Bishops and at some point I'm going to
try to grab the center with E4 and open
up uh the lines for my Rooks black still
has a very very solid positions but this
is uh my favorite as white I play this
as well and I'm enjoying quite good
results another idea in the future could
be Knight E5 and in case you play D6 I'm
going to transfer Knight to F4 via D3
Knight D3 Knight F4 and I'm going to
Target The Pawn on E6 very complicated
uh there's a lot of uh lot of ideas and
play left in the position thank you
Christian and we have some real uh
nuances very very subtle play that's
going on in the game between Anish and
Magnus as after this move C5 that was
played by Magnus not the move D5 but
castles was played and this Cy little
move Rook E8 it will take a an hour or
so to explain the nuances of that move
Bishop E3 not H3 but bishop or D5 but
Bishop E3 Knight G4 Bishop G5 H6 as we
say giving the bishop the boot where did
the bishop go back to C1 all the way
home it's very interesting how they
haven't committed both sides haven't
competed themselves to a plan because
you know black can capture on D4 and
take the position into more moroy type
positions right and white can also as
Christian mentioned go D5 play D4 D5 and
then the game takes Bon type takes a bon
type structure character yes exactly so
both players showing keeping their plans
as flexible as possible um from White's
point of view what white has trying to S
Suggest is this early Knight sorte to
the move to the square G4 really doesn't
fit into black strategies for example
let's say we have a move like Knight F6
on the board after the move D5 the
desirable move Knight D4 would in fact
be a mistake because that would uncover
or rather the Knight on G4 would be
exposed and after a recapture light with
the pawn uh black is losing material
because two units are actually onree so
the desirable Knight
C6 has an issue and after the move D5
Knight E5 again you have what uh Mark
doeski famously called the superus
knights after a move like Knight D2 uh
White has ideas of booting the knights
away with H3 and F4 and gaining a big
Edge in space uh Christian over to you
yes uh Yer thank you Knight D7 was
actually essayed in this position to
keep this Square C6 for this Knight on
H3 for the knights on G4 so in case of
H3 I'm going to take here take and now
I'm going to move this Knight on E5 and
it's very important as you were
mentioning if you go with a knight on C6
directly excuse me if you go with the
Knight on C6 you have this extra move D5
with Tempo so that's why Magnus is
placing his Knight on D7 and not on C6
because in case of H3 I could still play
something like this well of course I
have Knight takes D4 as well but Knight
E5 and then Knight D7 would uh would
would be a place for for my other Knight
but Knight D7 was played a game of
nuances as as you guys were mentioning
from the beginning and uh we're going to
see who's more accustomed to these type
of positions and uh who's going to have
the better creative ideas uh with all
the subtles subtleties involved I'm a
pretty direct guy I actually really like
White's move in this exact moment D4 D5
but let's first go to Maurice and share
his
thoughts another game that I've been
following is the one between
vishwanathan Anan with the white pieces
Maxim Vash GRA with the black pieces and
this one also features Superfluous kns
Al dorety this one is really interesting
because this is the game that that Anan
crushed npom nchi the actually played
some strange nidorf anti nidorf type
moves in fact he played his Queen over
to G five at some moment but you watch
the Maestro the best night off player on
the planet now Maxim Vash lra handle his
business and it was really cool to see a
couple of moves first of all the Knight
E to C3 as you see both knights fighting
over the D5 Square it looks like support
but this Knight is not really doing
anything it would rather be the one on
D5 it's kind of jealous of this Knight
sitting in the middle of the board so it
would be nice to trade it off in some
way Bishop for night well that's not
going to happen Black's not playing
Bishop takes KN under any circumstances
unless it's just concretely winning some
somehow but what I liked was this next
move Bishop to 86 just putting itself on
a long diagonal there's really nothing
on that diagonal that it's after except
slowing down the possibility of to move
F4 big strategic Point White's going to
have to get a break in somehow to make
this side work otherwise how is he going
to win the game but also leaving this D
Pawn hanging who's defending it he's got
two pieces lined up on this Pawn how do
you take advantage of it if you bring
your knight back to E3 black simply
plays Rook C6 and you can't find any
piece to attack that Palm with anymore
well defended so showing his skill his
finesse his touch in these types of
positions is mvl so he play this move
Bishop to H6 and Anan then continue with
the move
H4 and then the move Knight C5 by mvl
we're in this very rich position as two
of the heavyweights in the tournament
battle it out in this round thank you
Maurice and coming back to our
tournament leader Wesley so up against
uh Ian and the the game started as an
English but it quickly transposed to a
Queen's Gambit accepted uh type of
position and in this position after the
move Bishop E7 I wasn't looking forward
to it but I was rather expecting a
capture on C5 but the direct D5 was
played and the imbalance
of as you see my computer rushing
through the moves an imbalance of Bishop
versus knight with majorities for both
players on opposite sides of the board I
always like these positions strangely
enough for black yes I think it's easier
in Practical terms to play Black side
yes I I agree with you so I guess the
decision black would be facing is do I
give white the pass porn exactly and I
give white the pass Pawn but I blockade
it quickly with the move Bishop D6 and
this majority is a very healthy one and
it all comes down to uh the bishop
versus the Knight and principle this
Knight on F3 needs to find a a greater
pasture if black can erect and keep this
blockade he's going to have an easy game
and again Wesley so um leading the
competition all he needs as uh Nigel sh
very well said play steady calm good
chess and let the position come to him
right you don't have to force anything
and that's what he's been doing this
tournament he's been playing very calm
chess waiting for the mistake when the
mistake comes his consistency is
admirable Christian back to you another
game of nuances that uh I was looking at
is aronian versus ivanchuk as I
mentioned before the usual plan is to go
Knight E5 plan this Knight in the center
and whenever you go D6 which is the
usual uh move to open up the pieces
Knight B D7 uh Queen E7 Rook A8 and
concentrate your forces in the center if
Knight E5 Bishop takes G2 King takes G2
when now D6 and uh we see we see black
white is going could go Knight D3 and
have a perfectly fine position but Rook
ad1 was S8 with the idea that now if you
go D6 I'm going to go Knight E1 and we
see whenever you take on G2 with uh with
the bishop I'm going to take with the
Knight and I'm already going to be ready
to jump to F4 but I have this extra move
Rook ad1 on the board so we see a game
of nuances very very nice preparation by
aronian I know he's an expert in uh in
in this line so I'm expecting him to to
grab the momentum and build an advantage
thank you Christian we're shifting back
to the game between Onish giri and
Magnus Carlson the game has kind of gone
into the Hedgehog style Waters yes I
also I also a bit beused to see that
this rookie eight this mysterious Rook
move f it has a nice point to it and the
current position
that well because he's played B6 right
because this is this is sare KS of C6
square and uh Knight C6 is no longer so
potent because it's just an empty-handed
move after Queen C7 this p on E7 has
been protected in advance and I also was
noticing on the nuances this whole
maneuver of night G4 with black yes was
to provoke H3 which again weakens the
dark squares when you do put a knight on
E5 or attack or Knight E C5 to say to
attack the uh E4 Pawn so if white is
ever provoked into playing the move F2
F3 you sure would like that pawn back on
the H2 square right right so yeah
Christian oh well let's go to Maurice
first actually
yes well you know when you're play an
opening it's like your bread and butter
then when you see better players playing
the opening you pay careful attention I
know Christian you love the grinfeld
that's your bread and butter and you
always want to look very carefully at
the top players as they handle it very
exciting to see those lines appear the
night ORF is mine I play with the black
pieces and it's a tricky opening to play
because white always has a gun to your
head I mean white is always preparing
one of two breaks that just blow you off
the board sometimes three this one white
looks for is F4 often white looks for F4
often white looks for G4 sometimes H4
will happen but the night off is not
like the dragon where H4 H5 is that
effective but sometimes the pawns are
just coming down the board you're always
keeping a watchful eye on these pawns as
they see
restrain sometimes and especially with
this H5 move that came in Vogue
somewhere in the 90s H5 became more
consistent way of stopping any kind of
Advance with G4 so I'm looking at this
game and I'm just thinking okay mvl best
player in the world in the night off
what does he have against Anan Anan
played the move H4 so that this Pawn
doesn't get to H4 itself the black pawn
will restrain white side even more and
now this move Knight C5 and the last
time I was on the air just a few minutes
ago when I saw Knight C5 I okay that's a
typical move but there's no sort of
solid point to it other than the Knight
moving out driving the queen away the
queen doesn't really want to be on the
Square anyway Queen drops back and now
for a maneuver I don't think I've ever
seen after Queen E2 this move Bishop
back to D7 which confused me and then
F3 building the idea of G4 and then
Knight back to E6 this normally just
doesn't happen in this opening this just
a a weird construction where this bishop
backs up and then the Knight comes back
and that's basically tempting white
giving white a couple of moves for him
to be able to prepare his brakes so now
I'm starting to worry is black like is
this legit this is a new idea as far as
I'm concerned and now Anan played the
move Queen to
F2 and looking eyeballing this Square
here on C on uh B6 excuse me hit hitting
B6 Rook
to lashing out was unon with G4 sudden
suddenly and all heck is broken loose
all of a sudden white has executed his
main move black still has got the king
in the middle of the board the dewn is
always a problem at any moment don't put
a knight on D4 it's going to get sacked
on there's no question I is going to
play that move and look at the following
sequence takes takes and now Bishop to
G5 and now we're in weird country right
now and it looks as though this is
actually a blunder fight black because
Anan has played the scintillating Bishop
to
B5 and this is where black is being
exploited for what he's done he couldn't
take because of this pin but now he's on
tap to take once he opens up the H file
it's going to be a mating attack the
injures are going crazy now after this
last couple of moves as I was speaking
these moves landed and now they're
saying what has black been doing all
this time black is Stone Cold busted
right now a brilliant move by Anon
Bishop B5 refuting the somewhat I got to
say artificial looking play by black and
mvl looks like he's going to go down to
another unon brilliancy thank you
Maurice B5 I'm forcibly reminded of the
Guttenberg variation where the Soviets
were in the inner zonal were playing
against the argentines in three games
the argentines had a training camp and
came prepared for a sicilian night ORF
and they all reached the same position
the Soviet players waited for the great
FM Geller and Geller played Bishop F1 to
B5 and they said very good that's go and
the argentines got crushed by the
Soviets and this move Bishop B5 boy does
that hit the mark because it protects
the rook and uh Black's King is under
Dire Straits right um Christian over to
you well Bishop B5 is truly a brilliant
move but white in this position neom
Nashi had a much much easier way to
execute his opponent's uh blunders in
this position black Wesley so play the
move C4 you guys were considering the
move Rook takes D5 e takes D5 Bishop D6
to create the blockade and then in the
future C4 block blockade these pawns on
the dark squares and any end game would
be much better for black because of the
bishop instead of that black played
directly C4 and now white missed this
cute little move Queen takes C4 and much
easier tactic than uh vatan Bishop B5
which is a complete brilliancy and after
Queen takes A3 Rook takes A3 B takes C4
Rook takes A6 this is simply a pawn up
uh a play for two results instead of
that white played the move Knight D4
almost immediately Queen B6 was S8
getting out of the pin Rook D1 G6 taking
away uh the important F5 square and I
think the last move was A4 we have this
position on the board but after a move
such as Bishop F6 exchange the Rooks on
on D5 Rook d8 concent conate all your
forces on dark squares and once again
this Knight is a little bit uh misplaced
because of this Pawn on B2 if you live
the range of the bishop is going to open
up and you're going to have uh huge huge
difficulties with your obstructed pieces
uh this is looking good for black but he
dodged the bullet yeah well that was the
usual case of a double blindness and I
must say when you play the move C4 and
it's nicely protected by the pawn on B5
your feeling is okay I've secured it and
it's easy to believe your opponent right
and one other thing in that final
position that I I was thinking that
black is better also because his
queenside poor majority is very mobile
can move forward versus the SP on e4
which is kind of stuck it's stuck yes
and when you have opposing poor
majorities that is a very important
factor to consider clearly uh I turned
my attention back to the game of anishi
versus Magnus and I must say I've always
been partial to Black in these Hedgehog
positions let me just go back a few
moves where well it's easy for me say
queen D2 hitting the H Pawn H5 there was
a trade of dark squared Bishops as my
computer races forward Knight C5 E5
Queen takes E5 all that all happened
very quickly and uh White got rid of
this Pawn that on e4 that was rather a
weakness rather than a strength and
trade a dark Square Bishop so uh Magnus
has to be a little bit uh keep a careful
eye that moves such as Queen G5 and
Knight F5 doesn't land this queen is in
such a powerful position I'm expecting
Magnus to play the move Queen B8 are for
a queen exchange and I expect Queen
G5 but let's go over to Maurice for the
exciting night or that we're witnessing
Maurice
and honestly I'm feeling so much pain
right now watching my night off get
spanked it's unbelievable what is
happening to mvl in this game uh after
Bishop B5 he saw nothing better than to
play the move Bishop to F4 and after
Bishop takes King taking because
obviously Queen takes if just go back
one move Queen takes just drops the
Knight F6 check and that's all she wrote
Bishop takes King had to take and then
Knight A4 now the king stuck in the
middle of the board the threat to take
the Rook on C5 The Rook dropped back to
C6 and the queen just landed with a thud
down on the B on the A7 Square attacking
the B7 pawn and this position is just
busted your king Stuck in the Middle
there all kinds of crazy threats you got
to W watch out for Knight B6 would come
Knight C5 could come in a moment's
notice if you're not careful black in
trouble if black makes a move like this
of course you see the Knight B6 move
coming in what to do now in this
position the engines are giving almost a
full Rook advantage right now to black
and black just has no reason to like
anything about the position it's just
Rook out of play King in the middle uh
this position he did play King back it
looks like and queen takes on B7 Rook C4
is now on the board white up upon up
position up on the clock as well this is
just a straight demolition by the former
five-time world champion you see why he
is a former five time no there was
nothing Beau Queen A7 because you'd
think that B7 would the B7 PA would be
very easy to defend but there was no but
there was no nothing he couldn't go
Queen B8 because of Knight Knight a to
B6 check Queen C8 of course failed so
and if you allow the queen you know one
of the biggest s to penetrate right into
your the heart of your position oh dear
beastly beastly is what I'm seeing this
will NBL because at the minute he's
standing in second place exactly big big
result uh going on there back over to
you Christian Let's uh divert our
attention to the game between aronian
and ivanchuk once again because this is
a maneuvering game very very strategic
each player is trying to uh annihilate
the other's player plan and in this
position after Rook ad1 instead of D6 I
was mentioning that D6 would weaken the
pawn on E6 so vasil decided to play the
move Knight to C6 Queen to E3 was S8 we
see a lot of maneuvering this bishop is
going to go on C3 and then at the right
moment we're going to go Knight E1
Knight E7 Bishop C3 Queen E8 Knight to
E1 as expected Bishop takes G2 Knight
takes G2 and now we see Black's plan of
bringing the Knight via E7 rather than
D7 now he played this move Knight to G6
obstructing the Knight on G2 and
defending against the move Knight F4 if
Knight F4 will be played then Knight
takes F4 Queen takes F4 and the more
pieces black manages to to exch change
the uh free the more free his position
is going to become uh so I expect after
Knight G6 a move such as potentially fh4
try to play H5 then Knight F4 then Queen
to F3 and E4 at the right moment if you
divert your pieces on the king side with
Queen F7 Rook A8 potentially a queen
from F3 could infiltrate all the way to
to B7 and start collecting pawns uh this
is a maneuvering strategic game and
we're going to see which one uh is going
to be faster and more precise with his
plans thank you that final position with
h for it's a very risky what I believe
is a bit risky because it makes you a
little bit vulnerable to F5 F4 if
control I was trying to tactically
trying to make it work immediately with
ideas of C5 and then you
know
well mood this morning and uh just
looking at the MV versus vishy game wow
what a wipeouts going on not only does
white uh stand a pawn to the good
Black's Kings being chased and all of
Black's pieces really looking uh
Dreadful at this moment we've just seen
this move Rook C4 D4 nothing about this
game as Maurice nothing about Black's
position as Maurice was explaining is
attractive here it's just it's it's uh
full disaster as you would say it's not
a good game let me go back to the game
of Wesley so and check in on what oh
there's the Magnus game somehow and a
lot of Trades have taken place and it
looks very balanced so let's uh check in
on our tournament leader and see what
has happened when we left it we had just
seen this move Bishop F6 the Knight had
to draw back a rook trade that we had
expected and black has achieved just
about the maximum he could expect from
this uh opening a takes B5 now a lot of
us including myself would be most
tempted to play the move A6 takes B5
however in this particular case after
the move Queen takes B5 it's the old
double attack right Pawn on D5 is being
uh attacked Pawn on B2 uh nepo kept his
D6 Pawn because now you know he's put
everything behind the D6 Pawn he play D6
Bishop takes B2 got snapped immediately
and now we see C4 C3 is on tap for black
I like I like Wesley's position I like
Wesley's position as well the the D Pawn
on on the sixth rank it can't move
forward you know well maybe it can maybe
can maybe it can D7 it can because of
Rook takes Pawn then you have Queen EA
check correct but the but this uh SE pwn
also uh looking very good yes so
Christian over to you no Yan is is
taking unnecessary risks at the moment
in this position after Queen takes B5 we
see he could have S this move Knight to
E5 attacking the C4 pawn and now after
an exchange Rook takes D5 Rook takes D5
Queen takes D5 I can just simply play
Knight a C4 I'm going to have the
cooperation between the queen and the
Knight and my position is going to be
perfectly fine instead of that after D6
Bishop takes D2 I'm just going to snack
on that pawn I'm going to put my king on
the dark squares and where is your Pawn
going he's not going anywhere uh this
position looks almost on the verge of
winning for black uh let's go to Maurice
in l
a position that is on the verge of
winning for white well it's past winning
for white and you know when you have a
dominant position like Anan does and you
have all the open lines all you need
more open lines and so Anan said let me
open up the game some more takes takes
and mvl came back with the Tactical Rook
takes on H5 now that's one last gas
maybe Anan would kind of instinctively
play Rook H5 that's not going to happen
and allow Maiden one but the problem is
White had everything you could hope for
on this side all the peace placement the
perfect police placement in this
position all he needs is more open lines
over here so if he just moves his Rook
away and starts to threaten the king
this way that's going to be all she
wrote You've got nothing to do you could
trade off this pair of Rooks thank you
very much all these pieces are IR
relevant this check is coming in and
this is just resal there is nothing to
do here you you just can't make any
moves pure dominance by white so all has
to happen is that but it turns out Anan
did not looks like that did not happen
in the game let me just go back here
Rook takes H5 instead of doing that Anan
played C3 first which is still winning
but not as crisp he had this open file
idea inste he allowed Rook takes here
Rook takes here and he's definitely
still winning this in this position
looks like a move has not been made yet
still overwhelming Advantage for white
but he did miss a very very powerful
move Rook to G1 in this position uh King
f8 now has been played on the board King
f8 and okay he's still totally dominant
here so let's not make too fine a point
about it but he could have virtually
forced resignation by grabbing that Gile
so we'll see MV trying to fight back I
doubt that Anan is going to let him out
of his clutches though in this game
thank you Maurice and there was a nice
tactical uh trap that Anish giri had
laid when we left it we had seen this
position after Queen takes E5 I was
expecting Queen B8 Magnus calculated
that after Queen D6 uh there would be a
trade on D6 Rook F D1 and that he would
simply dissolve his Pawn weakness with
D5 I'm sure Magnus was feeling good
until he saw White's next series of
moves Bingo Bishop takes H5 snacking on
a pawn was played by Anish with the
obvious tactic that if the bishop is
recaptured Knight F5 with a check uh and
a discovery on against the bishop
winning his piece back with a pawn in
hand uh Magnus shot back with a
Desperado Bishop takes G2 and I believe
we're here at this moment but that move
Bishop takes H5 really turn the game in
White's favor because I'm looking at
King takes Pawn takes and with White's
Knight poised to jump to F5 uh the world
champion uh King is going to be a little
bit but without the Queens without the
que the queens and it's game and the
Knight the Knight on C5 can jump to
defend a king on F6 in time with Knight
D6 yes and we just saw that Anish was
about to make a move and what did he
do so he instead of Knight F5 he just
played the move Rook D2 instead and that
is boy I must say that that is real
restraint um by white I was really
expecting maybe some kind of King F3 but
Rook D2 and I like this move very much
by Magnus Magnus said okay my king
little bit in Dodge a little bit uh
under uh threat King
F6 protecting the square F5 asking white
what he's doing white just doubled the
Rooks and now Magnus to play and my fear
of Bishop takes H5 has been alleviated
it didn't turn out to be that powerful a
plan for white Christian back over to
you what are you game that we haven't
focused almost at all is the game
between Jo Bava and kumnick two
explosive players and these type of uh
structures I've seen in the game in
Paris in the game between uh mamed arov
and topalov if I remember correctly the
computer enjoyed Black's position but
black simply collapsed because do of
very a very very dangerous white attack
on the king side while your Pawn while
your pawns your majority on the queen
side is a little bit restricted for the
moment so in this position Knight to G3
was played we see all of white species
concentrating uh towards black Black's
King Knight to G3 is prepared to jump on
F uh F5 after a move such as H5 G5 and
then Knight goes to uh to F5 black would
like to exchange as many pieces as
possible and try to enter an end game an
end game this structure would be almost
winning you would play C3 or keep the
pawn on C4 and then A5 A4 open up the
lines and the pawns are going to be very
dangerous while white will not be able
to create any sort of mating attack if
uh if he doesn't have the Queens on the
board so in this position black played
the move Knight to E6 uh trying to
exchange the pieces and uh White is
still considering his options actually I
think H5 was played Knight takes
F4 and we have this position on the
board uh now this is a very very
complicated the engines still prefer
black but with low Time Low Time
controls an a mating attack such as this
one could be very very dangerous and
jaava is definitely feeling uh feeling
powerful in this position uh let's go to
Maurice in
Len well someone who should have felt
extremely powerful because the game
should have been over a long time ago is
vishwanathan Anan and I'm sure his fans
are not happy with what has just
transpired because in this position he
could take the PA on A6 and at least say
I'm up a pawn I've got two connected
passers your king is never going to be
safe for the rest of time in this
position but instead he played Rook G1
finally that move that would have won
him the game much easier earlier he
played it now and the night off
specialist pounce mvl with Knight to C5
and now the position is quite tricky
look at this e- pawn queen C6 has was
played this ewn is now a potential
weakness black is not going down any
concrete material and now the move Rook
to G5 shutting down this G file Rook H1
was played Here and Now King to G7 and
clearly Anan still has this incursion of
his pieces this king is still not as
safe as this one is definitely an
advantage for him but before we were
talking about the Game ending MBL
fighting like a beast right now trying
to survive will Anam be able to write
the ship and keep this Edge and possibly
win this game certainly things have
changed quite a bit over the last five
or six moves we'll see how this one goes
as it looks like the engines are going
crazy up and down with his evaluation
and I'm sure Anan is thinking to himself
you know this guy should have been dead
already what's going onely Maurice thank
you for that because it really did look
like that earlier Rook G1 would have
been lights out uh you give these guys
any opportunity to climb back into the
game they'll find it they'll find that
hidden resource
back over to you Christian absolutely
and in this position once again uh we
see the more conservative approach would
have been night8 C6 then draw back the
Knight to E2 and jump back to F4 and
then go G5 or H5 instead of that Jawa
play the move H5 burning all the bridges
Knight takes F4 was played e takes F4
consolidating uh the expansion on the
king side Bishop takes D4 I'll snack on
that karnick says uh and in this
position this is the this is what we
have on the board I think H takes G6 F
takes G6 was played the computers still
prefer black but from a practical point
of view I'm a little bit concerned about
this move Rook to E1 what are you going
to play let's say you're going to go
Queen to f8 Rook takes C8 Queen takes C8
and now I'm going to continue trying to
open up the lines towards your king of
course once again white has burned all
the bridges if his attack doesn't
succeed he's going to be completely lost
once this bishop moves away uh the other
the other Bishop opens up after D4 this
is just going to be all she wrote but if
uh if wh's M mating attack succeeds then
jaava is going to uh get his first point
and enter the scorecard let's go to
Maurice in Len
quickly well this game is giving us a
heart attack it's unbelievable what has
happened here now it looks like white is
lost from a completely winning game in
this position after Knight C4 if mvl
finds this fantastic rejoiner Queen to
h8 White is on the back foot and busted
why of course you cannot take this queen
because it's made in two down here and
that's game over what a beautiful
construction with the Knight the bishop
and The Rook extreme Harmony in that
position and otherwise this Rook has to
start hiding it's separated from the
rest of its Army and you start looking
for squares to go to if you go to D1
then it's Black's Revenge as the queen
leaps into the game with Queen to H5 and
suddenly it's black on the attack about
to come into F3 mvl missed the move I
just saw another move come in Queen h8
could have happened but this seesaw
battle continues as he's taken on e4 and
now you saw the engines go crazy and
saying now he's actually lost this game
is crazy hard hard to play obviously the
time situation but it looks like they
had enough time to find these moves but
the pressure of the game the many
vicissitudes of this one has just been
absolutely unbelievable and it looks
like Anan is back in control and should
be winning according to the engines but
I'm not even going to talk about who
might win this game because it's just
been a Madness thank you Maurice and
that's why the Sicilian nighter
continues to Captivate generations of
players because of the Topsy Turvy
nature of these attacks when they when
they go wrong they go really really
wrong and by the way that move Queen
h8 uh should not have been that
difficult to find because the maiden two
is pretty Sol evid so mvl with a big
Miss had he won that game he would have
been tied for first right absolutely
that would have been a big one but there
you have it uh after Knight takes F4 uh
you see the queen on e4 Queen on Pardon
Me The Queen on C6 was was attacking the
Knight on e4 that was why mvl had to
play uh Knight G3 and this looks a very
nice opportunity here for um vishy vishy
has moves like Knight H3 and uh I
wouldn't doubt for a moment that after a
move also like Rook D1 he'll be in the
driver seat D1 looks very simple and
very good you know then the D6 Pawn will
be falling yes with a night coming in so
yes in a in our another Marquee matchup
uh game uh Anish Gary and Magnus Carlson
are fighting the way their way into a
rook and pawn ending looks like that
game's about to be a draw after the move
Rook C4
oh I was just yes stop it I was just
about to suggest uh a move boy I can't
okay I'll just let my computer have its
fun and the players seem to be blitzing
out their moves and I'll turn it over to
uh
chrisan players are getting Queens on
the board and it looks like uh two
versus two and a queen andish is
eyeballing eyeballing Magnus saying a
draw is it time to uh a Haring of the
point a Haring May yes maybe suggest a
Haring of the point Grand Master ship
yes and uh here it comes oh he didn't go
well it's a check I was expecting uh
King E7 very very
breezily uh continues our world champion
king back to E7 and queen D4
centralizing and apparently Magnus was
waiting for the draw offer so a hard for
game Christian over to you because the
excitement in the Wesley so game is
absolutely in the game between Nashi and
Wesley so let's see how white tried to
get some sort of counterplay uh for uh
for Black's extra pawn and in this
position after Bishop a Queen E7 was
played attacking The Rook supporting the
pawn D7 Queen D7 to uh to to challenge
this Pawn on D6 and potentially attack
it with Bishop A3 and then just grab it
with Bishop takes D6 Rook takes D5 very
powerful move Bishop to A3 this is the
position we have on the board at the
moment black is simply just threatening
to take Queen takes E7 D takes C7 and
then Bishop takes E7 uh annihilate all
of White's counterplay Queen F6 has to
be played and now black could
potentially take uh take the easy route
out after Bishop D6 Knight to G5
preparing Rook takes D6 Queen takes D6
Queen takes F7 and that's a Checkmate
but we have this cheeky little move
Bishop H2 King takes H2 Queen takes D5
Knight takes F7 Queen takes F7 and after
Queen takes d8 white is going to be able
to find the Perpetual if black is going
to try to for a win after Queen F6 he
could play a move such as um Rook E8
perhaps no Rook E8 is bad because of
Knight E5 so Bishop D6 H I think has to
be played and after Knight G5
potentially uh Bishop H2 and that's just
going to be a draw so it seems like
white actually found uh his counterplay
let's see if uh if Wesley managed to
find a way to get out of this well thank
you Christian Ian a very resourceful
players adds is the entire field uh just
when you think you have your grippers on
them they lip away and this move uh
Bishop H2 I thought was a winner until
you look at the nightes night takes F7
right you go wow what a nice counter
shot so an exciting uh game going on
there again just to say Magnus Anish har
for draw um let's go down uh well this
crazy game between mvl and vishy
continues to have our uh cantion just
not go Knight takes D6 well let's just
go back to the position when Knight G3
was played after Knight G3 Knight E6 uh
vishy decided to give back and Knight
takes D6 with the threat of Rook F7 sha
was on tap so King G6 has been the last
move and uh by the way just pay
attention there are some sneaky little
checks that you have to be careful for
uh black
piece knight G3 King G6 Rook G5 make a
strange impression but I'm I don't quite
see The Knockout low and making LT with
A2 A3 keeping all his threats in the
position um was vishy and the Knight
still can't be taken on a D6 right
Knight takes Queen takes D6 is punished
on on the spot Queen F7 check and mate
uh uh going back uh to Christian you've
got that joke of a game on to this is a
crazy Affair guys and jaava is spending
a lot of time in this position because
he simply cannot find the the counter
play Rook E1 has to be played if you
play a move such as F5 try to open up
the lines I'm going to play this cheeky
little move Bishop G3 controlling the E1
square and preparing my Counterattack
with D4 and this is just game over
completely lost white simply hasn't
doesn't have any sort of defense against
uh the opening of the light Square
Bishop so if jaava doesn't find Rook C1
and he's down to only 5 minutes on the
clock to Crown EXT then he's going to be
in big big trouble and we could
potentially see his seventh loss in a
row that that would be tragic yes it
would it would indeed uh just looking at
the game between leavon ronian and World
rapid Champion Vil ivanchuk we have um
yeah position before that let's go to
Maurice in Len
you know a lot of classicist purist
prefer the classical game they like the
purity of it the Perfection of the moves
the Artistry and it's absolutely can't
can't blame him chess is all about
making all those precise moves and
playing masterpieces but rapid chess
proponents will say but this is where
the fun is this is where Anything Could
Happen mistakes will get made and you'll
see Wild swings of Fortune if you're a
classicist you don't want to hear about
that you want to see best moves and then
the rest of it happens but a game like
this is so absolutely entertaining Anan
first mvl played a bad opening the way
he handled himself was not accurate Anan
showed exactly what was wrong with it
Anan built up a winning position could
have won the game very straightforward
fashion with this move Rook G1 missed it
the game turns around and M mvl starts
fighting like an animal to get back in
the game so much so that unan messes up
and it's mv's turn to find a win which
he also misses with all the pressure and
all the complications and now they're in
a protracted struggle it feels like I
I've gone through three or four
lifetimes with these guys watching this
one single game it's just absolutely
incredible and now mvl in this position
has played the move Knight to F5 his
King exposed in a way he doesn't want to
but at least it's material equality and
there is no knockout punch for Anan if
he now plays a move like 94 since his
Knight is now under attack mvl can play
a check King nice and snug happy behind
those Pawns and then this move Knight to
G7 and disconnecting these pieces and
saying get this Rook out of here let my
queen in somehow this is bad for black
obviously because the king doesn't
belong on the Square but it's not just
some big punch that knocks him out and
with the clocks ticking down now un on
at 5 minutes and 46 seconds MV at eight
minutes he's got a Fighter's chance he's
had worse positions in this game already
a few times now trying to fight back is
mvl just an incredible struggle why
people love watching Rapids thank you
Maurice and entertaining indeed I mean
if that doesn't keep you on the edge of
your seat you're you're not a chess
lover cuz that is really an
extraordinary game Christian what do you
have yes in the game between nepom Nashi
and Wesley so I've mentioned Bishop D6
would be the safe way out and that's
what actually happened on the board
Bishop D6 Knight G5 and in this position
Wesley is still ping his his next move
Bishop H2 would lead uh to the aention
draw variation uh instead of that
instead of Bishop takes D6 C3 would have
actually kept uh kept the tension in the
position and would have given white some
problems because after Queen takes uh C3
I'm simply just going to take on D6 and
this is going to be a pawn up of course
white still has a lot of initiative
because of this combination of the queen
rook and Knight the Knight could
potentially go to G4 at the right moment
and create some mating attacks but if
black manages to retreat the bishop to
f8 place it on G7 very very safe around
the king and then use his a pawn this
could potentially be a very long day at
the office for white but wesle so is one
of the most risk averse players in in in
in this competition and he is he is
taking the easy way out he the players
are going to make a draw like uh exactly
as you uh prescribed it might Ur some
time ago the game yoga did find that
move
Rook uh to E1 and that game has exploded
again I mean the Head Hunter joa always
in with a puncher's Chance uh I was a
little bit surprised that uh um Vladimir
uh gave up his Queen for the two Rooks
and I'm I'm looking at this move F5 well
he took that decision very very he did
very quickly over to you Christian
absolutely did Vladimir make the right
decision uh well Vladimir make the
practical decision but jababa found in
human moves to survive in in this game
F5 is the only move that survives uh
giving up this bishop on B1 but the
problem is if you take on B1 I'm going
to go Queen to F4 and once again we see
your pieces are a little bit
uncoordinated they're not ready they're
not primed for the attack if you manage
to get this bishop out of the way defend
on G7 and open up the bishop on A8 then
this is just simply game over uh from a
practical from a strategical point of
view from a tactical point of view
there's nothing saving white
unfortunately you still have to find a
way to coordinate your pieces and queen
takes H6 is coming once again we see the
uh combination of Queen Knight and pawns
surrounding uh the black king and he
might have some problems let's see if
kick is going to take uh uh the bait on
B1 uh practically he shouldn't do that
he should focus on the defense for the
moment Player move such as G5 try to uh
control White's initial
on the on the king side and jaava is
still struggling with his time
management he's down to only 2 minutes
ouch ouch and that's difficult thank you
Christian boy I tell you uh one of the
one of the uh times I was most nervous
in my chess career I was playing in the
US Championship where a certain Mr
comron sherazi uh one of the great uh
players on the Swiss tour was in the
tournament and it started with some
horrible score like oh and seven and it
was my turn to pick up the point all
right but he was such a dangerous player
and there we do have a draw uh I felt
incredibly nervous playing against a
player that I simply had to be to keep
pace and I don't know if Vladimir is
feeling the same nervousness uh because
Jova is giving points to
everybody Vladimir says me too and who
knows this game could easily easily go
uh the other way shirazi who is actually
French right now I think yes orig from
IR he checkmated me a couple of years
ago so I know he's a very very dangerous
player he Ed a very unconventional plan
on the king Side open up the H file and
then just checkmated me I had no chance
wow and by the way after the move F5 I
liked especially your move G5 shutting
trying to shut down the King s side
Vladimir krck has just played this move
Rook
F6 uh giving uh your have some uh
nibbles maybe the queen F4 Bishop E5
Queen H6 exposing Black's
King comes with a check oh well G4 has
been played G4 G5 has been played G4
G5 again you
know car's a big club and he loves
hunting his opponent too much I think is
this asking too much to go G4 G5 maybe
maybe maybe but we'll definitely be
keeping keep a close eye on this game
and that game uh between mvl and vishy
I'm almost afraid to ask what has
happened in that game let's go to
Maurice and find out
yes I'm catching flies on every move I
mean it's unbelievable my mouth is like
what what just happened again it's
unreal what is happening in this game
but it looks like Anan is starting to
get his grips on mvl that exposed King
is what it's all about this king is just
little too too exposed too open un
onplay the move Knight to C4 in this
position excuse me uh after Knight at5
he played the move Knight to C4 and mvl
needed to play this maneuver Knight to
G7 instead he played Knight to G3
instead looking for his counterplay and
King A2 stopping this queen F1 idea now
E4 pushing his pass Pawn down the board
while your king is in trouble I said
wait a minute I'm going to play Rook
back to H3 and hey I have a queen H7
have an idea in the position there's
some tactics all over the place your
king is being squeezed and mvl said no
problem let me March my king up the
board what I was like what is happening
in this game Anan chased the king with
Queen to H7 and now King to F4 boldly
marching down the boort with this King I
can't believe this is going to work but
remember mvl had this dead loss game
against crnic in the tournament early I
think it was around three uh that he was
simply dead in the water the engines
were up somewhere like plus 15 aonian
said that he predicted a draw in that
game he said as long as mvl has some
checks whenever he has some checks it's
okay he's not going to lose I was like
that's ridiculous but somehow mvl is
like a cat landing on his feet I can't
imagine him surviving this one Anan has
now played the move Queen C7 E5 you
don't see Kings look like this every day
Anan is obviously looking for The
Knockout Punch the only chance it's 3
minutes and 30 seconds left on the clock
for Anan mvl with 4 minutes and 27
seconds in this absolutely ridiculous
chess position for black but somehow
he's creating a wall with his pieces and
daring un on to find them what can he do
anyway looks busted but he is fighting
back the Frenchman showing why he's one
of the best defensive players in the
world remarkable game simply remarkable
game well you know there's not that much
time on the clock and and you know it is
true that the computer says it's complet
completely winning but it's he ping a
human and everyone this is very
surprising and then VII has to sit down
and work
out how how he's supposed to reel in the
entire point and the great thing as well
is this eorn can could be very it's a
potential right I mean that is ready to
trundle and the E5 Pawn but it is
absolutely confusing uh mv's very very
slippery he's trying his best to to to
make and non work hard and the position
is tactical the last move by vishy by
the way I really like very much he just
played the move Rook H7 looking to play
the move Rook F7 check and if the black
king is forced to go to the Gile then we
have a an additional 93 check I think
this was the right move um it it
certainly felt like the human move
computers will play this uh type of
position that's so tactical near you're
perfect but I tell you with your clock
ticking with such an unusual
configuration of pieces it's really easy
trust me really easy for for for uh
White to go wrong Christian what do you
have for us uh the game between jaava
and Kik is getting wild and Kik seems to
be uh getting ahead because of jaa's
time trouble situation uh in this
position after Bishop E5 jaa's attack
could have been successful after Queen
to G5 if you take Rook takes B1 I would
go F4 and once again we see the
combination of the pawns Queen Knight
pieces are a little bit uncoordinated
Black's pieces the bishop on E5 is under
attack Rook on F6 so White's attack
could potentially be successful uh the
engines still prefer black but
definitely P from a practical point of
view white has a good chance of saving
this instead of that after Bishop E5
jababa took the wrong pawn and if Vlad
KY take finds G3 Bishop takes G3 he's
going to be winning let's go to Len with
Maurice
CRA well yeah Cardiac Arrest definitely
the case I I need a doctor in this
building right now because what's
happening is ridiculous Anan had a
winning blow with the move Queen A7 to
bring his Queen back to the F2 square
but instead he play Queen B6 creating a
disconnect with this Rook so instead of
just cold winning this move suddenly
brings mvl back in the game Queen to G8
hitting the rook and hitting the Knight
hanging on the C4 Square trickery by the
Frenchman here and now the move Queen to
F2 with cck was played and the engine
saying it's no problem now for black
after King to G4 okay now it's saying
black is winning in this position black
is winning I've got to update my board
to get to the game position because it
looks like black is suddenly up in
exchange hello let's get back to this
one right here
after we're we're here Queen J Queen F2
was played King G4 Rook G7 Queen takes
Knight E3 looking like uh that's good I
don't get it after King back suddenly
everything is defended and oh if he
takes here there's a queen F7 check
happening so Queen H2 check King to G6
Queen takes G3 Rook G5 and suddenly the
king's defended black is up in this
position Queen H4 and black is the one
who is winning this game right now Anan
has to be shaking his head in this
position after Queen H4 the king is
still exposed so you want to make a
prediction uh-uh this one is nuts but
still somehow MV has turned the game
completely around and he is winning in
this position we'll see what
happens I need a
doctor thank you watch out for those
flies I tell you jaw dropping experience
he will be absolutely aan will be
absolutely a gasted what's happened
because well I mean this is rapid Chess
at both its worst and best but
entertaining
absolutely because uh what I figured
that aan missed was that his intended
blow after Queen F2 check was Knight E3
and he forgot that Queen F7 actually put
the Knight yes in an absolute pin and
look at the players go they're in a
blitz mode we've got the live board up
above us on our right we've got our
analysis board on our left um vishy
v vishy um looking for a Perpetual check
it's not overwhelming uh for MV and Vish
is going to have to find some trickery
uh to stay in the game but we know those
Knights are treacherous where the
where's the the petu I mean I don't see
it I don't see it either but Queen E8
check King has to go to H4 Knight goes
to
D5 oh and we have some news devel KCK
has won his game on Time against B J
Who's now on his seventh loss in as many
games ouch that really really really is
painful so the it's all gone wrong it's
all gone wrong for
jooba and we'll go to the end of that
game but I'm still keeping my eyes we
have to keep an eye this game between
vishy and mvl what's the time situation
well VY has one one minute just 1 minute
20 seconds and uh the King on G3 looks
awfully safe it looks really safe I told
you about that pawn on he said watch
that pawn yes you did and guess what
that pawn on e4 is indeed ready to March
up the board E3 on
to3 surprises keep coming I hadn't
expected that one but it looks like it's
pretty pretty good as well because uh
Queen takes C4 check uh will suddenly
expose White's King and if white if um
vishy takes a moment to defend the pawn
um it's not enough Queen F6 Queen boy do
you want to make a prediction not
me Christian uh any takers what's the
over and under here no I definitely uh
like what black is doing and he has more
time on the clock he has the the
advantage so I think he's going to uh
convert this but you never know but you
never know it's it's just been um
amazing game okay we have the situation
uh black can't push his Pawn now because
the Rook needs protection and white is
just you know fishing for some kinds of
chances this is an instant kicking in
just to buy yourself some time but of
course with the delay time there's no
increment there's no increment so and MV
has given up given up his an exchange
because he's count he's banking on the
fact that in a queen and pawn ending um
his his pawns being the quality pawns uh
will win the game for him and it's very
important that he has the double pawns
because he can cover his King with the
double pawns uh I think this is this
should be an easy conversion for uh for
black uh especially because of time
situation as well is very very difficult
to defend uh this type of Queen end
games with a few seconds on the clock so
I don't see a Vue surviving this one wow
wow
yes so atast take a breath right
well there's a little trick here
actually if and uh I was going to say if
Anand had played King D4 queen queen C3
would have been a nice techm oh oh we
got to show that for our viewers oh boy
I first maybe on your board uh Christian
because my computer just will not let me
analyze yes uh so what Joy was saying in
this position after Queen
H3 doesn't want to go to D4 which seems
natural but unfortunately after Queen C3
this is just simply game over this would
have been Maurice's heart attack yes
okay but where bring us up to date with
the current position mvl has marched his
King all the way towards White's King
which yes uh in order to try to escape
these Perpetual checks and if Queen B1
I'm simply going to go King D2 and then
I'm going to March my Pawn e32 E1 um
after after King C2 I think he's still
thinking we have Queen F2 on the board
but right now Queen D2 could be played
and then the king finds a way to uh to
hide from the checks and then E3 E2 E1
is just going to be
played if we have Queen D2 check as
you've recommended Queen C5 check King
D1 Queen takes E5 pawn moves forward to
E3 you know I've seen so many um studies
where the guy promotes the pawn and it's
two queens versus one Queen but there's
actually a perpetual check that's
inescapable it's rather the remarkable
study like idea this is not a study but
it does look like mvl will win one
exciting exciting game oh my goodness
and we do have um E2 on the board at
this exact moment it looks like this is
a position King
A2 uh was played by vishy and now black
needs to figure out how he's going how
he going to want to promote his spawn
Queen D4 backing up so that he will be
able to play King D2 oh that's a isn't
isn't that a
blunder que3 why I was thinking King up
A5 useful little move that there are
times that you could play A4 maybe bring
your queen to B3 with a check to try to
force a trade of Queens this looks and
by the way practical in in Practical
chess it's really really hard to play
this position for white
uh it's losing to begin with but tively
losing and very easy to playy to we're
looking at King D2
now green G2 to pin the porn and now we
we always toss in a check because it's
just our instincts to toss in a check
and if you play King to A2 let's toss in
one more check and now do we do we press
with A4 or we just simply move our King
to a groovy Square maybe D1 yeah yeah
this looks like it's going to Queen F3
to maintain that
pin a A4 A4 White's actually running out
of moves here let's go to the webcam so
we can see the players uh nervously uh
with the times 46 seconds there's our
shot as mvl has gotten in the move A4
and he's just played Queen
E5 I think the easiest way to do it is
maybe just to post up with the queen
queen
E3 he has not played that he's play King
E3 he's going on the king side because
white has less squares with the queen to
give the checks oh very that's crafty
that's that's very smart yes indeed
Queen D5 Queen D1 game over wow vishy is
probably
wondering where did it all go wrong well
we know where it went wrong with Rook G1
but he'll be smarting on the outcome of
this game Christian your thoughts on
this incredible incredible game I have
to admit I wasn't paying that much
attention because I was letting Maurice
uh do the work but uh the game was
insane and we we've seen so many crazy
games this round we see Jo Bava game
once again uh he's on seven losses out
of seven games possible he is uh he is
complet he's a man down and he's going
to be very very difficult to recover uh
kumnick uh I like the fact that he
bounced back he has a good chance of
recovering and Magnus Carlson solid as
always wesly so solid as always uh this
is going to be an intense finish uh to
the rapid portion definitely amazing and
I just have to go to Len because Maurice
was just you know watching this unfold
and uh just jaw-dropping game that was
going on here uh do we have uh macea
let's go to
marce this is one of the most memorable
games I've ever had the chance to do
commentary for it just simply had
everything you wanted all the drama just
simp just simply incredible incredible
struggle by mvl what does it take to
kill this guy he's like the zombie Who
Never Dies the the man was dead against
konnik somehow saved that game this one
now he was dead against vishy and
somehow wins that one as well just an
incredible Defender this was 80 moves
long and we felt the marathon of this
struggle tremendous game of course Anon
will be disappointed about not finishing
him off but we will interview the man of
the hour as he has moved into second
place clear showing that he is indeed a
force to be reckoned with in this
tournament thank you exciting round and
after that round what is our current
standings well there you have them to
2016 tour Champion wesle Soo is still in
the lead with 11 points out of 14 in
second place with his with his
remarkable Houdini Act is a maxim VRA on
10 points out of 14 and in third place
world champion Magnus Carson on nine
points um then we have a tie for fourth
between Ian npon and Ani so still
everything to play for and but the
things just keep getting worse and worse
for B he he's lost all his games all
seven of his games to languish on no
points uh death spiral indeed going on
there and by the way the game between
leavon and Ron andil of G did end end in
a draw a hard fought draw at that well
the queen Indian as we all know is a
very tough not to correct indeed and I
was that because we're just so
mesmerized by that
well Swindle Houdini I think I mean how
how to describe mbl's success in this
event well let him yes let let well
let's find out for ourselves Let's uh
let's go to Maurice who has an interview
with uh
mvl well I don't know what kind of
potion they have in Paris but whatever
you've got mvl I want it because you had
a busted position against crme they
managed to survive what happened when
you saw this move Bishop B5 appear on
the board it wasn't
I mean your brain must have been going
oops but somehow you managed to survive
there were so many body blows that could
have ended the game what what made you
have the tenacity survive this one well
my point was to find Moves In which at
least I didn't see an obious clear cut
way to win I mean even because every
move I was playing I was like no this
wins this wins this
wins and uh I was like of course my
position is busted but you know whenever
I would find a mve I mean I would still
be fishing I mean this is basically the
way I play and uh I mean it turned
out that I mean I don't know how many
clear WIS we she missed because well I
was not really I mean I was trying to
find positions where I couldn't see a
clear wins so I mean I mean it probably
doesn't mean anything I mean they were
probably in every line like two or three
clicker TNS but uh you know little by
little turn and already I felt like you
know my position is not that bad and
then here you yourself missed the
clearcut win with this amazing queen h8
move you told you after the game yeah I
was looking for I mean for some coun to
play but somehow it didn't cross my mind
and yeah after I took on4 and suddenly
it was back to to a long defense and R
inan my position must still be busted
but there some I always managed to find
what I felt were were only moves aonian
who is a very very good friend of yours
he said when you were playing against
Chic he was predicting a draw because as
long as the Frenchman has some checks
it's always good you did you hope for a
draw in this one when you were playing
what were you hanging I know you were
hoping for a draw but were you hanging
your head no after Bishop B5 I already
thought you know I'm going to go with a
loss but uh you know I kept on fighting
because this is uh this is what we do
indeed it's what you do well we could go
over this game for the next two hours
but I know you have another game coming
up congrat ratul on this Victory and
best of luck in the rest of the games
thank you Maris guys thank
you I need to to catch a breath a couple
of house uh keeping notes one we want to
inform our viewers is we do have a
replay of the wonderful tie break that
that occurred in Paris between Magnus
and mvl brilliant brilliant play by
Magna so that is coming up as well as
and uh before we go into that we also
have a an interview with the players and
their thoughts on actually playing in
lven I don't think we
have okay sorry I think we have actually
an interview before we go with the video
clip that has been prepared but boy uh
again how many decisive games and if
they weren't decisive they were hard
fought yes oh well let's go to Len and
uh with Maurice with Nigel
short Nigel uh with Nigel short of
course Nigel uh this game makes you
think uh maybe
retire CH what does it take to beat mvl
the way he's playing we played amazingly
at the end of Paris now he was dead in
the water twice against two of the best
players in history let's not put two fin
point two of the best players in history
and he managed to survive these games
well it's it's simply a question of
precise calculation at I say simply it's
much harder than that what it means is
that at a certain moment you just must
calculate five moves ahead and be sure
of it and uh vishy had several
opportunities in that game to put him
away and he missed them and you can't
play
on general principles all the time I I'm
oversimplifying of course he's
calculating but sometimes your
calculation is a little bit too shallow
and you need to just to calculate five
moves accurate moves and then it's all
over yes he had that power punch but the
way mvl interviewing him the way his he
moved his body as he said he couldn't
find a wi and he just had to sort of
fish through if he couldn't find the
wind for the other person I may make
this point it it's like he it's almost
like he he was inside the position and
just flowing like it was some kind of
martial art it the way he played like he
was defending like a martial artist well
the the the technique in these positions
has basically explained is to avoid
playing moves that lose instantly so if
you just can push the defeat slightly
further away uh that's all you're hoping
to do you don't set one cheap track
which if he sees then you resign you
just try and push that uh defeat just
make it a little bit hard and uh and
wait for him to make a blunder and it
came and more than one blunder and more
than one indeed I'm visibly reminded of
but strikingly reminded of one of my
favorite movies of all time the Matrix
and I'm seeing keano Reeves Neo ducking
dodging bullets well n will hope he
won't have to dodge any more bullets
that one was absolutely insane and we
expect more Insanity to come as round
eight will be beginning in a few minutes
slippery as a huh good good defensive
psychology there like the the attitude
you should have when you're defending be
positive you know it's
nice and we will now go to our player
interview on on well the interviewing
our players on how they feel about
playing in Len and uh then we'll move on
to round eight thanks to the break see
you
[Music]
soon I really enjoyed spending time here
last year and this year we're an even
better Hotel uh right next door and so
it's the dream tournament literally can
come to the game 10 minutes before it
starts and you're fine it's a pleasure
to be back in Lan I mean the city is
nice it's not too far from Paris people
actually speak French as well I'm from
artistic family and uh somehow the playe
way you know is really it's really
beautiful it's like a museum and it's
like a piece of art when I explore a bit
a city it's really nice place nice
weather and everything is to create the
good good games I think good energy yeah
i' played here last time in the same
city hall uh we got a little tour around
the what was yet to be uh to become a
hotel and we were told you know next
year we're going to play here and now
we're excited that uh you know we we are
at this new hotel and uh it's a lot
closer much better location then last
year you know the rooms are uh very
fresh you know just the smell of paint
is barely gone so disappointing how fast
time FES it's been a year since I was
last here and it felt like just
yesterday it's a beautiful uh Place uh
but most of all I'm happy to you know be
back playing playing chess beautiful
venue just next to the playing hole what
else can the chess player ask
for
[Music]
this year we're fortunate enough to be
able to bring some artifacts from the
World Chess Hall of Fame collection as
well as the sink field collection to um
spectators at the Grand chess tour
installments in Europe it takes a full
team to travel an exhibition of this
size um introducing new artifacts
popular artifacts highlights from our
collection to a global audience is very
exciting for the World Chess Hall of
Fame as we expand our Outreach to Europe
this is the first time many of them have
been out of the country and it's our
first traveling exhibition some of the
highlights are the board signed by Bobby
fiser and Boris spasy following the 1972
World Chess Championship and the pieces
from game three some other highlights
are the Paul morphe silver which has a
special connection um to one of the
venues here Paris because morphe himself
traveled to Paris during part of his
[Music]
career
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
he
[Music]
[Applause]
he
[Music]
n
[Applause]
[Music]
he
hello and welcome back to round eight of
our rapid chess format wow I have I'm
gasping for Breck that game between the
swan Nan and MBL was a game for the ages
just watching that unfold and it was
really hard not to laugh because we were
seeing this engine evaluation completely
from left to right it was like the Hot
Potato Point uh in an incredible Houdini
like swindle once again mvl found his
feet and that is why he is keeping the
pace exactly with Wesley so as he's in
clear a second what a time to have a
documentary being made on you it's
brilliant let's take a look at our stand
look at standings yes so still in the
lead is our 2016 tour Champion Wesley so
on 11 points out of
14 close behind him is mvl on 10 points
out of 14 after that fantastic win in
third place is our Champion Magnus
Carlson nine points out of 14
and let's take a look at our new
matchups for round eight and
okay old
rivalry vadir and V Vil Wesley so still
in Pole Position against leavon aronian
two of our favorite picks and I'm
looking down at that rematch two-time uh
rematch world champion mag Carlson up
against thison at n and I tell you it's
so hard in chess you've got to put the
last game out of your mind and just
focus on the new one the new one is
worth as many points two points and
vishy uh he's still smarting I I'm
smarting and I'm a professional
commentator here and I can't get it out
of my mind exactly this is going to have
to I this will hurt for for vishy he was
so easily winning and when he I I mean I
think he will have to go back and find
out where the winds were and yeah he has
to calm himself down and also another
person who has to calm themselves down
is B Jo joa who is languishing on no
points and he has to get rid of this
death spiral that he's current in I and
I just really don't have uh advice other
than what the old Soviet advice was when
bleeding just make a a safe calm draw
the problem is it's not in his nature he
has no uh safety mode there is just uh
aggression aggression aggression he's up
against the very solid Anish AI jobava
just again he's lost all of his games
can't he's going to get somebody that's
going to happen it's it's inevitable
happen right yes and will it happen in
this round well we'll see let's pick up
the action with Magnus and vishy as soon
as I find that uh game on my
uh board we will go to it that's the
game of Wesley so a London uh system Ian
an
mvl that's a great
Clash um and there we have it so uh
Magna started with an English C4 E5
vishy true to his Bishop B4 and an early
E3 Knight G2 by Magnus I don't even know
what this variation of the English is
called but we have this position of the
board I can easily imagine D2 D4 what
else to to do and for vishy vishy really
likes these reverse French types of
position I don't think E5 E4
immediately is the right choice perhaps
castles is the most let us say solid and
leaving it up to White to decide and if
I playing very safely just you know
because I'm you know because I need to
stop the bleeding could I take on D4
or is that
to Yes uh it looks uh it's quite a
reasonable move uh also to take on De
wow Magnus played D4 D5 okay threat
alert uh D5 D6 trapping the bishop but
simply D6 by um black vishy uh ready
develop comfortably developed bring his
Bishop to F5 as Knight on D7 he'll
capture on D5 and try to utilize the
cfile by moving his Bishop to B6 um well
we know that uh for Magnus Carlson he
just looks to play a position not
necessarily getting anything major out
of the opening this looks to me like
vishy will be satisfied and Magnus too
Magnus has his play well D5 is a very
committable move right indeed it is very
committ I mean especially if I back it
up with E4 it kind of feels like it's a
very bizarre Kings Indian type structure
where maybe yeah but in this particular
case suddenly this bishop will swing
back to B6 and it'll have a say
Christian what do you think about the
position well I'm very happy to see
Magnus in his element playing
unconventional chess in par in Paris we
saw him playing D4 E4 the usual very
normal play right now he's experiencing
because his confidence is at an alltime
high once again after his win in in
Paris so I really enjoy to see seeing
Magnus at his Peak confidence levels and
right now we have a c reverse Sicilian
on the board the bishop on C7 is going
to have some uh some difficulties
getting out because of the fact uh that
the pawn on is not on e4 but on E3 so
white is just going to go Knight G3
Bishop E2 develop his pieces Bishop B2
and uh is just going to be a normal
position black has to find his counter
play and I think uh that's going to be
on potentially on the queen side if he
decides to play A5 Knight A6 try to
create some weak squares weak dark
squares so that this bishop can uh get
reactivated uh for the moment this is
just going to be a long maneuvering game
but I definitely like magnus's chances
and magnus's style of play thank you uh
Christian I saw I see in the game of uh
yova he's repeated the very same line
that he played with
mvl uh and had a bad outing with mvl I
don't know what it is that joa finds
particularly attractive about this
position for white and he's just played
the move F2 F3 uh this night on H4 is
making a very pathetic impression on my
mind I don't I don't get it uh I don't
see the attractiveness for white uh
quite frankly and that is one game uh
for a niche we have to keep our eyes on
a niche he's playing very well very
confidently and successfully in uh
Len yep and he's just played the move
Bishop H3 and it's quite clear that uh
with one
move Bishop E7 it's going to be game
over on the spot so again I'm just you
know shaking my head wondering what it
is about this particular line that
doesn't make any sense you can't if you
go like you said Rook F2 Bishop B7 G3
gives up an exchange which well may just
give up more than that because again
this night uh is looking really pathetic
G3
F4 sorry uh cover your eyes here
everybody this is not uh what this great
Georgian player had in mind when he's
when he started this tournament it's
just like everything that could go wrong
has gone wrong Christian no absolutely
and Baba does have a lot of experience
in these type of positions he has
analyzed it countless of hours at home
the problem is he does in this time
control he doesn't have time to actually
find the most creative ways of getting
out of trouble and unfortunately
whenever he gets down to 2 minutes the
decision making process is simply
nonexistent so that's his biggest
problem at the moment uh jababa did play
the move F4 the only move to save that
Knight Bishop to E7 and now I'm
expecting a move such as Queen did three
uh again the problem is I'm going to
retreat my Bishop on G4 and your knight
on H4 is still going to be uh in a quite
problematics Square uh the structure
favors black uh let's go to Maurice in
Len just a quick note on this game after
the round I stepped outside just to get
some fresh air to make sure that my
pulse was was beating properly or at
least calming down after the last round
and I saw jababa walking around coming
back from getting a drink uh I think it
was coffee or something and I said to
him what's going on you know how you
feeling and he said this is just
ridiculous I'm missing one move uh wins
this is just really insane and uh then
he said you know I'm just going to have
to save this in the blitz he's just
really waiting for the blitz to come and
I when he said that I quickly reminded
him I said you got two more games so you
know settle down and and do well and he
said sure thanks and then he walked on
so he's already looking past these two
games guys that's dangerous to just sort
of be putting up the white flag in the
Rapids and saying I'm just not playing
well here and somehow he's going to have
to bring it together this is not a great
start at round eight to do that so we'll
see whether or not he can get his mind
right but as he said he's he's really
just past this now and not caring about
these this particular phase of the
competition which is a big big mistake
because these are two points at
stay Point per per victory in the blitz
it's one it's EXA so the these uh these
games have added weight and well Queen
C7 by Anish I fully understand uh the
move the queen on B6 wasn't uh doing the
utmost uh King H1 um I still like well
what can I say still like uh black
Black's position very much we're
expecting the move Queen D3 not
protecting the Knight but inside going
after the bishop the bishop will drop
back and of course we can see that this
Knight on H4 is still floating in the
air the queen on C7 eyeballing that F4
Pawn so in case the knight ever drops
back there is a queen takes f4 on tap
let's go to uh some other games at the
moment and yes one second just one
second because this game has entered
uncharted waters jaava did play this
move King H1 which is actually a
strategical blunder because after Bishop
E7 which was played instantly by by giri
the problem is you no longer have to
move Queen D3 because after Bishop G4
your knight is actually stuck Knight F3
runs into Queen takes F4 so that was the
whole point of the of the move Queen to
C7 after King H1 Bishop E7 white will
have to actually take on H3 but after
Bishop takes H4 look at the structure
the pawn on F4 is completely vulnerable
if I man to bring this Knight Knight E7
King B8 Knight C8 Knight D6 and
potentially land it on e4 that is game
over uh the structure is just terrible
uh I I'm not really sure what jababa has
missed because Queen C7 you could
instantly see what the idea uh what the
idea behind is very good and going to
our tournament leader wesle so he's up
against leavon it was a London defense
system against the ready opening that uh
uh Wesley likes that essay C4 quick
capture on C4 right and A4 so that black
doesn't have any long-term ideas of B7
B5 trying to uh maintain this Pawn on C4
Knight D7 Knight A3 ready to C recapture
but leavon said no I like my pawn bishop
takes A3 Rook takes A3 giving up the
pair of Bishops and Knight
H4 another set of Bishops another set of
but uh wow um Knight H4 that's just well
it looks so unconventional looks like a
mix of the cannon opening that we all
played as beginners A4 Rook A3 but let's
go to Maurice and and Len pardon me to
uh see what's attracted his attention in
round
eight well once again it's NBL playing
enterprising chess it's sort of like to
him it doesn't matter what the position
is this is rapid and you have to play
quickly play intuitively if you don't
see a loss make the move and let's see
what happens next and he's done that in
this game if we jump back to this moment
in the game this was a solid position
for black black had maneuvered his way
out of the opening quite well and
looking like he's not having too many
issues maybe even threatening a move
like Knight to B6 eyeballing this Pawn
trying to prove something white could
have played B3 very solid chess no
problems instead mvl said take your
solid chess I'm going for E5 of course
this Pawn is attacking the Knight but
after Bishop takes Knight your queen
can't leave because your Pawn will be
hanging in this position Knight takes
what happen let me just play Queen takes
on the board and suddenly Knight takes
E5 thanks for the pawn so instead he
said well my plan was to create the
fractured Pawn structure now having the
light squore Bishop we'd say the two
Bishop Advantage you know usually it's
not really about the two Bishops it's
about the bishop you have that the
opponent does not but after this move he
played the move Knight to D5 and now F4
surging ahead guarding his Pawn looking
like he might thr an F5 so Knight to B6
going after the two Bishops mvl said I
wasn't even thinking about the Bishops I
just want to attack he goes ahead with
F5 e takes F5 was played Knight takes F5
suddenly the Knight is hovering around
the king G6 was played Knight check King
to G7 and now Knight back to G4 this
move exposing the king to a check on 86
and suddenly mvl is starting to cook
again and his intuition is just
remarkable right now he's playing with
complete Freedom just throwing the
pieces out making moves trusting himself
he looks like maybe the most confident
person in the competition right now he's
only at one point out of first place
against Wesley so but his games have
just seemed to be the freshest the most
entertaining even when he's busted he's
just playing like a man who has nothing
to lose and keeping us all on the edges
of our seats thank you Maurice success
breeds success and failure breeds
failure that seems to be the um what's
going on in this tournament with joa and
uh mvl in the field uh wow I like uh
very much the attack that uh mvl is
constructing uh weak and dark squares
and this move Knight G4 setting up
nicely uh for this bishop H6 check uh we
have a Frenchman on the role but you
have another game to show us uh
Christian I do I have the game between
the former world champion kramnik and
the current rapid world champion
ivanchuk vasili and we have this
opposite side Castle position in which
white is Pawn storming on the king side
black is trying uh to uh let his Pawn
roll on the queen side in this position
Castle was played in in the idea behind
is that is that after G5 I'm going to go
Knight H5 and I'm going to take control
over the F4 square if you take on H6 I'm
going to be right in time to play G6
solidify the pawn structure on the king
side King H7 Knight F4 and despite the
fact that you are a pawn up it doesn't
really matter because you don't have a
way to open up my king but Vladimir
kramnik sa a very very typical plan
after Castle he played this move First
bishop to H3 now the threat is I'm going
to play G5 and then I'm going to uh
create a problem in your structure after
Bishop Tak E6 F takes C6 and whenever I
take on H6 let's just see uh potential
variation Queen C7 was played on the
board G5 Knight to H5 I'm going to take
first damage your structure F takes C6 G
takes H6 and now whenever you play G6 to
block my attack to stop me from coming
on the G file the problem is your G6
Pawn is a little bit weak I'm going to
play Bishop E3 take control over the F4
F4 Square you cannot play Knight G3
because of the move Queen G2 and this is
just game over Queen G6 is coming on the
board and that's Checkmate and uh this
is just an unstable Pawn structure for
black with a Pawn on F7 that would have
been very stable very nice strategical
Edge for black unfortunately with a Pawn
on E6 which we could see in the next
couple of moves uh this is going to be a
difficult defense because of the
pressure on the G file thank you
Christian and yeah that's a scary
position for
black indeed I I turned my attention to
the game Magnus Carlson vishy and Nan
these two great uh players uh Rivals uh
vishy did play that move A5 that we
expected and he did get uh some dark
squares over on the queen side you see
my computer uh bringing us up to date
with the players now this last move is a
really nice little cheeky move I love
this move by Magnus basically it's
saying your Bishop is doing something
but I'm going to leave it high and dry
and the bishop on A5 actually blocks The
Rook on A8 on the open file so basically
what Magnus is saying is I want to leave
those two pieces stuck essentially on
the queen side and while they're doing
nothing over there I'm about to play as
white the move F2 F4 opening up this
bishop on B2 and turning the theater to
the king site nice attacking ideas here
good good strategy let's go to Maurice
and
Ling well right about now was getting to
a point where you could probably just
follow mv's games only and you'd be
entertained for the rest of the
afternoon because what's happening over
here is just completely ridiculous first
of all you saw him allow his pawns
structure to be fractured then somehow
neppo took on F5 and allowed this Knight
to do this nice dance to G4 with the
threat a bishop 86 so it looks like the
Rooks got to move is the most natural
thing to do yaser I know you would
probably smack yourself three times
before you actually play this move G5 I
mean incredible move opening up the
diagonal weakening all the squares
around his King and of course Bishop D3
was
instantaneous of course mvl is thinking
I smell blood now in a position Bishop
dropping back and instantly his
preparation for this nine was the move
C4 getting space on this side I mean
this King just looks so wrong I mean
this of course this bishop can go to E4
he can go to F5 he could park wherever
it wants what's the justification for
this Pawn formation nomachi has had his
share of bad positions as well both
these players have played Houdini in
this tournament remember when nomachi
was dead lost against Anish giri and he
just played like a wizard to get out of
that game so we have two Wizards playing
in this position now crazy crazy chess
happening on mv's boards and certainly
this game is going to be one you wonder
what is really going on is positional
chess just dead thank you Maurice slap
myself twice nope Thrice uh G5 would not
have been uh anywhere near my candidate
my list of candidate moves and after the
move G5 weakening as Maurice was
mentioning all those uh light squares on
the kingside in ly the bishop on C4 re
uh yeah it's completely I'm baffled by
this decision you know because this
bishop is light squared is the one
that's unopposed I I here I think is I'm
trying to read into the mind of Ian I
I'm thinking you know in for a penny in
for a pound his idea is that after H7 H5
this bishop blocks the um defense of the
Pawn on E5 and after for example Bishop
takes D5 Knight takes D5 Knight
E3 well I can't actually gobble I want
oh but I could play
no well okay I'm at a loss I think that
Ian's uh really in trouble should he
follow it up with H5 but wondering was
go H5 maybe I can go forward with my
Knights and just I don't know H5 Knight
F6 you meet yeah maybe looks very very
promising as well uh both pawns on on G5
and H5 are hanging I guess I have to ooh
if I have to give up an exchange I don't
believe it I simply don't believe it for
white uh but this is one of the things
yeah the queen on C7 I might not take
the H well you have to consider it Jo I
mean if there's a Pawn on pre you have
to consider the capture of the pawn but
of course you're right you would not
capture on
H5 well what can I say it's it's another
Donnie Brook in the making year
Christian what do you have for us uh in
the game between kramnik and vasil
ivanchuk Kik just missed a huge chance
for a brilliancy very very thematic
break in this position kic play the move
Bishop E3 taking control over df4 Square
he still has a very very solid Edge Rook
G4 Rook to G1 Queen to G2 are coming
really quick
and is going to be very difficult to
defend on the G file but instead of that
he could have essay this move F4
breaking black structure opening up the
queen uh V to go to G4 and uh attack the
king side after a move such as e takes
F4 E5 is very important as the first
move because after Queen to G4 you have
this move Rook F6 defending all the weak
squares instead of that if you do play
the move E5 first you're going to take
away the that F6 square and D5 Queen G4
is simply just winning instead of that
if you take on E5 I'm simply going to
take back and again I'm uh bringing all
my forces towards your uh your weak King
and this would have been just game over
uh instead of that white did play the
move Bishop to E3 he still has a huge
Edge Rook G4 Rook G1 Queen G2 is coming
and I don't see vili surviving for for
long let's go to Maurice in in
yeah I'm pretty sure I don't understand
Chess at all cuz this stuff that's
happening is just so mystifying in this
position here the move Rook to d8 was
played not anticipating this shot Queen
to F3 with the threat of Queen F5 and
it's going to be all she wrote if that
happens but wait a minute maybe he did
anticipate it because he suddenly plays
the move
F5 what is happening on this board F5
not supposed to be great for black but
black is punching back and by the way
although black has all these significant
weaknesses in the position you can see
it around the king it must be noted that
black is the better developed side Rook
on A1 Bishop on C1 not playing in the
game right now black has every single
piece in the act so you might cash in
with white only to find out that you're
down in Tempo you remember that game
that npan saved against konnik when he
was worse but then suddenly he switched
it around and gained that activity that
kic finally said wait a had to beat beat
this guy off of me and the game ended
being neutralized into a draw so Neo
understands that if he can keep dynamic
balance the dynamic balance going
despite whatever is happening to his
position if he's dropping material if
he's positionally compromised then he
still will always have a chance and
that's the kind of move that F5 is the
pawn has indeed been snapped off right
now and the engines are not even caring
about this side C3 is the next move
according to the engine to start
attacking on the other side and saying
okay you've got what you're going to get
but if your pieces don't come into the
game what advantage do you truly have
this is just an amazing concept by white
by black to give away everything give
away the weaknesses give away the pawn
even and say I've got dominance on this
side C3 how does this bishop ever get in
the game after moves like a move like
this one getting his counterplay that is
the move we anticipate by nepo simply
incredible 2750 2780 maybe even 2800
chest that these guys are playing uh I'm
in awe indeed I have to re-evaluate all
of my chess understanding you know
voluntarily creating weakness says but
this is where the computer engines have
so impacted top level chess they show
defensive resources that uh the older
Generations would not have considered
and this incredibly bright Talent uh Ian
um demonstrating a c a kind of kg modern
chess where you know you seize the
initiative even against the cause of a
severe weakening of the King right yeah
a c3a I find that completely unexpected
I would be imagining some form of action
against the pin you know I'm too direct
and uh going uh to this game uh for a
moment between Anish giri and joa Jova
well we well what can we say uh it's
been a spiral um jooba played the move
H5 Knight takes F4 ttic yes Knight takes
F4 we had been expected but then would
have come Queen H6 taking advantage of
the pin Knight so Jehova thought that he
would play Knight E5 uh check and uh the
bishop Desperado move that he had
anticipated this move Bishop takes D5
with a discovered attack against the
queen could he possibly save what looked
to be a really awful looking opening uh
position we'll keep our eye on that but
back to that huge matchup uh Christian
between Vil and Vladimir absolutely and
it seems like maybe kle has a connection
to our broadcast because after Rook to
F7 he did play the move F4 e takes F4
Queen to G4 was played Rook to G8 and
this is the position we currently have
on the board uh after Knight takes F4
black is going to have to get his Knight
displaced from this a very good blockade
Square on H5 Knight takes F4 will have
to be played Bishop takes F4 and at the
right moment I'm either going to go uh
H5 and attack your Pawn structure or I'm
simply going to retreat my bishop and
then attack you on the file we see
whenever we have opposite side castles
very very important is uh the speed of
the pawn storm the speed of the the
white spawn storm is incredible black is
still H is still very very far away from
opening White's position also all of his
pieces are displaced to the defense side
and uh his offense is definitely
struggling this is a very very difficult
position for black and I expect uh White
to be able to penetrate quite quickly
thank you uh Christian uh in the game
between Magnus Carlson and uh
vishan um Knight G4 h 3 Knight
H6 uh has been played I had anticipated
the move F2 F4 Magnus prefaced that
Advance with a move Knight H5 why did he
do that well he's looking deeply into
the position he's hoping that when this
diagonal opens up he wants to be um
Johnny on the spot and grab that pawn on
G7 the game continued F5 Knight G3
Knight H4 and we and anticipating that
uh F2 f44 will be played it has to be
well needs to be played uh in order to
bring these Bishop on B2 into the action
again I'll mention uh a comment from
before if white can successfully keep
these uh two pieces the bishop on A5 The
Rook on AA out of the game he's simply
going to have more Firepower on the king
side and by the way white would be
dreaming of a move like E3 E4 in such a
position explode open make use of these
offside pieces again precisely J okay
back to you chrisan F4 was played and I
was and and I want to ask you guys one
thing what are you going to do after the
move G6 I was just considering to
sacrifice a piece how the question is
how you have plenty of ways to actually
do that right I'll use all of my 25
minutes to to find oh well okay this
this is the correct move move E4 yes
very very strange uh mechanism in my
opinion I would definitely be looking at
F takes E5 first which is not a bad move
but after d takes E5 after this move E4
I always have the move F4 to counter
that and block the pawn structure
instead of that white has to immediately
counter the center open up the position
if you if you do take the piece then I'm
simply going to take on F5 and this is
going to be a slow initiative well maybe
not so slow in a couple of moves you
might get checkmated once these two
Bishops open up the Knight goes to H5 F6
once this diagonal open and again you're
playing without a lot of pieces uh all
your Defenders are on the on the queen
side while all my attackers are
definitely on the king side ready uh to
capture your king it's early days Jo V
but if
Magnus uh pulls off you know a brilliant
kingside attack we'll be talking about
another fantastic strategic Masterpiece
this is rapid chess folks these the
players only have 25 minutes with uh per
side with a 10-second delay but some of
the ideas that Magnus has brought to
this tournament have been incredibly
good good enough to say that these These
are classic this a classic and if G6
happens in E4 which is again highly
instructive of when to open up the
center in this I I I I agree it is
Master we are looking at a masterpiece
in the making wow and uh again just the
simple simple idea that it's the quality
of the attackers versus The Defenders
these two pieces you know you almost
could take off that Rook on B1 although
I I bet you uh pennies to Donuts that
that Rook on B1 is going to have a role
uh in a kingside attack but that Rook on
B1 can get uh over to the king side and
Black's piece say even though he may be
a night up at the end of many many of
these lines he's going to be in trouble
there's too many attackers I mean if you
take that Knight on H H5 another one
will join in Knight takes G5 and again
if you open up with e takes F4 this
bishop is unopposed on B2 on B2 Knight
F6 is coming you get to open up the game
and exactly and your pieces flood the
king side and the Knight on H6 and the
Knight on
H4 G was plate G some days you just got
to tip your hat and G6 is the obvious
question because uh again the Knight has
no Retreats it's all full steam ahead
and this move E3 E4 I love this word uh
from Mickey Adams that's visual okay
yeah that's a very visual move E3 E4
exploding uh perfect timing uh Christian
back to you yes absolutely and I want to
look at this game because we might see
jaa's first Score first point half a
point in this event because after Queen
G5 it seems like he's going to be a he
liquidated enough material and he's
going to be able uh to create a
Perpetual after a move such as king
takes C5 I'm going to go perhaps even H6
with the idea to go Queen G7 and I think
white is definitely out out of the woods
I think we're going to see the first
draw in in jaava scorecard let's go to
Maurice Inver
and this fascinating struggle between
mvl and nomachi continues remember the
engines gave the move C3 here and said
that black was fine but jababa decided
to play much more dynamically with
Knight to F4 trying to exploit this
setup along the file mvl found the
technically best move here with Queen to
A4 Queen to E4 but after Knight B D5
suddenly these Knights were connecting
in strange ways now the next couple of
moves the engine gives a move H4
yeah right whatever that feels totally
inhuman and abnormal even though it
looks like you might be doing something
but it's not even clear what your threat
is because he's going to be able to take
back in this position any human would do
or most humans would do what mvl did he
said these pieces suck I got to get rid
of them and he just traded off this one
Bishop takes F4 Knight takes F4 and just
developed his pieces quite naturally but
this position it doesn't keep the same
kind of Sting he had before after a
trade and we're looking at a potential
endgame with Bishops of opposite colors
even though he's up a pawn this Knight
on F4 is entrenched on that square so he
decided I don't want to see the full end
game let me play this move Rook to E1
and again black can play with C3 and
play in the dark squares so very
fascinating defensive skills by Neon Mii
we used we called Sergey kakin the
minister of defense well these guys must
be his secretaries or right-hand men
because they're showing their skills as
well whenever they're in danger how to
get out of trouble thank you Maurice boy
uh just great games across the board um
uh Christian uh back to you because I'm
still reeling from the previous round
well kumnick is still in full control of
the position in his game against vasil
ivanchuk he still has uh the very very
powerful pressure on the G file and uh
the better placed pieces but
unfortunately he's down to only 5
minutes on
while vuk is thinking and thinking but
he does have 18 minutes to uh to think
so the more we we approach the
two-minute Mark when when the nerves are
starting to be a little bit shaky and
the blunders could pop up at any moment
um you know the the the least the result
is going to be obvious for us so kumnick
still has a full control of the position
but his time management is is far from
uh from Good from ideal yeah
uh well uh going to the game of Magnus
Carlson uh vishy took the night having
said oh E4 was play E3 E4 E4 as expected
by uh Magnus Carlson and now this is a
tricky moment because you've got three
captures and you want to make all three
at once you want to take on E5 you want
to take on F5 you want to take on H5 and
it's a very awkward thing in
grandmaster's chess when you're sitting
there in a situation where you have
three very good captures and you've got
to carefully calculate which one and
which precise move order and you can
burn a lot of clocks sometimes you just
have to be practical and I'm thinking a
a practical move would be E4 takes F5
but the most practical for me at least
is Knight takes H5 J your view no I I
was also thinking e takes F5 is the most
practical for
me e takes F5 and explain why you you
feel that way well the pawn can't be
stopped I mean this is the thing he
can't blockate anything nicely on F6 and
then I can back this up with Knight
takes H5 you see because you can't Capt
it back on F5 and you know I I can
maybe I'm looking forward to F takes E5
and then some and then a knight takes H5
I I just if I go takes Knight takes H5
first then maybe
after e takes F5 I can't I can capture
back of black but your logic and
reasoning seems very very sound sound to
me um it's just kind of like how you
feel about the position Knight takes H5
makes sense E4 takes F5 makes sense
which was play which was play he takes
F5 he takes F5 oh okay I thought you
have instincts of a world
champion nicely done um and again from
Black's point of view black starts
looking you know where how do I hold
things up where do I go myself and the
problem is from Black's point of view he
would probably love something of this
nature where you know his Queen you know
tickles there's some tactics the problem
with as I see it E5 takes F4 Knight
takes H5 and this diagonal what we what
Magnus has been dreaming of you're going
to have to block it with an exchange and
I just don't think uh it's enough
it's a leaky Dam you know right not much
of a dam actually here the airbag
defense is not going to be working uh
after a move like Rook E5 so I see vishy
in trouble but having said that you as
Nigel was mentioning you've got to make
it as awkward you've got to present
problems for your opponent I'm also a
little bit worried after f after e takes
F4 is that suddenly I started
visualizing if I can put a queen on the
G line that's G game over right you put
your White Queen somewhere somewhere
somewhere there you give a check and
it's game over yes and so I'm thinking
that how do you do that how do I do this
how you get over there well as we
struggle let's go to Maurice let's get
to Maurice
yes well one well-known principle in
chess is that the bishop of opposite
color positions are often a draw but
that only applies mainly or should say
mainly applies to the end game the
middle game is a totally different
Affair and it all depends on who has the
initiative because if if a person has
the initiative in Bishop obos color
position it effectively means that
they're using a piece that their
opponent cannot oppose and this is often
a telling Factor if you're attacking and
you keep all the pieces on a bishop
opposite color position could be
dominant in fact as opposed to Simply
equal and dsh well this position black
is down upon a clear Pawn his King looks
somewhat uh challenged because the the
pawns have advanced but there's no way
for white to organize any direct attack
against the position so in this position
the Pachi said I'm going to ignore you
for a moment play this move C3 and after
B3 Dro The Rook on D2 and suddenly The
Rook is sitting on the seventh Rank and
now the move E6 was played and Bishop to
C5 all of a sudden well let me go back
I'm sorry let me update the board I
think theet was a bit
different we're right here so sorry
first it was Knight E3 Bishop to C5 was
the first move that was played that's
correct and now the sequence with Rook
to D2 on the board and we had this
position and now Queen to F3 has been
played and so we have this on the board
The Rook on the seventh the bishop on
this diagonal the queen look at the dark
Square pieces black has put everything
on dark squares except this one H Pawn
to just say you have the light squares I
have the dark squares they're playing
almost on separate color complexes or
both sides except black has his firmly
entrenched on dark squares and creating
all that harmony with his pieces and now
he can even play the move G4 with the
threat of Knight H3 check if this were
to happen white would virtually be
forced to sacrifice for this Pawn he'd
get two pawns he already has one so
that' be three pawns and he'd be okay
that's what nomachi is looking at right
now because that's his most natural move
but he doesn't want to give white the
sacrifice so how does he develop any
initiative if he doesn't play that move
turns out as I'm speaking he did play it
he went he assessed all the issues here
it's certain that this sacrifice is
coming and it has in fact happened
Bishop takes G4 mvl not one to miss an
opportunity like that he's taken on G4
we could expect this to happen next
followed by Queen takes G4 and now
trying to make this King be a weak piece
but the dark squares it looks like he's
going to be able to hide along that
color complex somehow uh this is indeed
a crazy position but it looks like it
may Peter out into a well I going to say
draw but you know predictions are so
pointless in these games completely
sharp position very instructive the
insights one can have in looking at
these types of
situations this again is rapid chess
guys it's just so fun to watch them play
on this High a level and be playing this
quickly thank you Maurice I mean I'm
almost afraid to ask the engine is going
to give triple zeros a position where
you think you know like crazy things are
happening and if I were black I would be
satisfied with the gain of Peace bring
my knight back to G6 I'm feeling pretty
good about myself but that of course was
not happen uh Ian played the move King
H7 and we've got another Donnie Brook
going on over here I I wasn't expecting
King H7 because I'm afraid of uh Queen
coming to F5 or H I wasn't I was
thinking H4 as well could be well the
one thing I really like is if I were in
white shoes uh we talk about color
complexes and playing on light squares
Queen F5 check with the idea of maybe
Knight G4 and the reason why I'm
attracted to the move Knight G4 is I
want to get my Rook into the game into
the attack I want to say so I'm trying
to play E7 but let's go back to Maurice
with an update on this crazy
game and in fact he made a mistake
instantly with this move King to
H7 I mean it's just like you you can't
guess anything in these games like I
said and it turns out that right now
white has a move that I remember seeing
Magnus Carlson yesterday uh it was his
game against jaava when he won the pawn
on D6 we didn't get a chance to
interview him but he wins The Pawn on D6
if you go back to that moment in the
game everybody most people would say I
have a Pawn on D6 I'm going to keep this
pawn and consolidate around it and then
I'm going to just Crush you with this
extra Pawn he could have done that the
engines say he was better that way to
seemed like the automatic way to play
instead he decided in this position to
advance his Pawn he played D7 giving
away his pawn and it turns out it was
the absolute best move give the pawn up
and play for dynamic peace play with
better coordination when I saw him do
that I was thinking like wow these guys
are so amazing that they just instantly
realized I have material no big deal
just throw it back and I get everything
for it
in this position the move E7 is
completely winning according to the
inches and as I was
speaking what was played E7 by mvl just
another quick toss you can have my Pawn
I'm not a materialist I'm a dynamic
tactician and this is what mvl is saying
in this position E7 a tremendous move
threatening to Queen the pawn you can't
take with the queen because your
Knight's hanging this queen is Tethered
to this Knight and if you tap with the
bishop suddenly the move Knight to F5
hello your Bishop is hanging on this
Square mate is threatened on that one
sure it's kind of easy to defend both
you say not quite Rook down to E7 with
check and that's all she wrote you can't
take with the bishop because of the mate
you cannot capture with the queen your
queen is taken and after Bishop takes
there's no mate back here so uh hello
give me your night and this is busted an
amazing moment in the game NE piai
missed this move in this moment of E7
let me get back to it E7 and it did not
take anything at all for mvl to find
this kind of shot just shows the level
that these guys play on 2800 chess might
as well be chess from Mars the way they
just find these alien type Concepts
instantly to them it's just another day
at uh the park another day another
stroll in the park not a stroll in the
park very exciting developments have
taken place in the game between vishy
Magnus Carlson white vishy and non black
Magnus has made this really cool uh
night sacrifice and oops as the as my
board catches up after the move ghf E4
trying to make White's life as difficult
as possible vishy has um won it's pardon
me given back an exchange uh trying to
make um Whit light white life difficult
easy for me to say uh we get the supera
nights we've been seeing a couple of
these Moes of these Knights uh very
important move G2 G4 not without risk as
well uh because black if black could
have gotten in this move H5 H4 that
would have been a permanent Outpost G2
G4 well the position is exploding uh
well Christian I
mean what can we say about this one no M
Magnus is definitely playing very very
inspired chess he's in good shape he's
is putting a lot of pressure on his
opponents and he seems to be dominating
uh the field at the moment but another
guy that's dominating the field is
Wesley so he's playing very precise
chess he doesn't make any mistakes and
we have this game against uh against
aronian Levon and we see once again the
double Bishop the bishop pair but
unfortunately you're still
underdeveloped you you cannot get this
Bishop from C1 out so you're still
struggling uh finding the best mechanism
to get to get these Bishops rolling so
in this position he played the move E3
Knight takes A4 lost the pawn but opened
up the aile very very important aspect
of this Pawn sacrifice B3 was played
everything with Tempo you're trying to
get your pieces out with Tempo these
players they don't lose any time at all
and you can see Black's pieces are a
little bit uncoordinated this Knight on
this side The Rook on this side these
two pieces on this side they don't have
a lot of good squares so after Knight to
B6 Bishop to B2 Queen to B5 Rook A1 was
threatened and Rook takes A7 H3 was
played now you see that the knights are
forced to uh to to draw back Knight to
F6 was played Rook A1 Knight to E4 D3
once again push your Knights back Knight
to F6 Rook takes A7 and I think we have
a few more moves on the board
but white is simply dominating we see
both Bishops feral Bishops active
Bishops they're ready to check made the
king uh The Rook on G5 came to the
attack you only have one Knight
defending that important G uh G7 Square
so uh this position is very very
difficult for black at the moment the
two Bishops are cutting the board in
half and uh this is going to be if uh he
maintains his Precision a win for Wesley
wow looks like it's very very
smooth th far you know the two Bishops
in open positions usually dominate the
the knights and in this exact moment uh
without any uh material compensation for
the two Bishops uh you really got to
like I forgot to mention aronian is down
to his last two minutes dang that eight
minutes for Wesley a minute 30 seconds
for leavon looking tough and those kns
really have got no no post no I mean
yeah no great outp no great Outpost no a
game that is going very quickly Mo uh
swimming right right along as the game
between Magnus and vishy uh Magnus
playing with great confidence he's
moving quite quickly and the the feature
of this position has has been for the
longest while that Black's pieces on
Rook on the queen site have been
stranded The Rook on A8 as well as the
bishop on A5 are not paying any are not
helping
the black king uh cause here and quickly
G5 has been played by um Magnus and now
he's essay one of uh our favorites ideas
of course The Rook over as well as the
more uh direct G6 G6 I couldn't find a
killer blow after after King f8 no I
didn't see one either I really like you
this idea of The Rook lift oops I my
computer I tell you I going to have to
give it a
reboot uh so uh for the moment keep that
in reserve that shot G5 in reserve G5 G6
in reserve which keeps the knight at Bay
and instead of one Rook lift he did the
other one yes exactly he spots the
targets and H7 and that's what he's
going for H7 indeed is the target I I
thought that this Remember The Rook was
on B1 I thought the Rook was going to to
come across I'm one of those players I
believe in inviting all the pieces to
the party right you know the Rook on on
F1 I figure is already in it uh let's go
Rook A2 to H2 but Magnus the world
champions Choice was Rook F3 Christian
back to you why did he choose that Rook
not the other uh it was actually the
better choice your intuition once again
didn't fail you yaser uh it failed the
world champion unfortunately because
after Rook F3 black is having a very
nice defensive maneuver Queen to f f8
Rook to H3 Queen to G7 next I'm going to
bring my Rook uh to f8 and then
potentially I'm going to jump this
Knight all the way to G6 Knight h8
Knight G6 and I'm going to start
pressuring your pawns if I manage to
exchange the Queens if I manage to enter
an end game this Pawn on D4 is going to
be a very very potent Force for for
black and uh if white doesn't manage to
uh take advantage of the weak squares
the H7 Square the the black weakened
King uh then he's going to be in trouble
the material unbalance favors black in
case of an ename is all right just a
question there to the final position uh
is there a defense to uh say if white
decides to double on the H line so we
just seen the move Rook F3 it's black to
play Queen d8 looks Queen pardon me f8
looks very natural and would you like to
do it with King G2 or Rook
A2 not sure King King G2 allows some
kind of H6 as a defense if that's
potentially potentially but maybe King G
D2 I don't really want you like the king
to G2 idea or perhaps I would like to
keep my king there and do your Rook A2
yeah I wanted that a moment ago myself
yes uh one of the problems as I see it
and is we've been seeing these really
Ultra strong pass pawns being tossed so
let's say Rook f8 Rook H2 there's the
shot in the position oh the engine
really didn't like the shot that I was
about to propose I think the engine
might have liked night takes G5 right as
a a pre no he didn't like night I was
going to say night takes G5 followed by
uh D3 okay H6 H6 maybe H6 yes H6 well
we're all wrong I mean three strikes and
you're out and then that that goes to
show that the position isn't quite as
level as
as the computer we have we have some
developments in the position um by the
way I think in that position Queen G6
was actually the move to try to force
the queen exchange thank you but we have
the live board up above the move was
Bishop to D2 Rook takes A8 Queen takes
A8 Rook uh Queen takes D4 and now uh the
bishop drawing back to B4 ready to go
Bishop C5 uh and and try to create some
mating threats against the white king
queen played was played but again the
Knight next to the king is extremely is
an extremely potent Defender and the
queen coupled with the bishop that
action should be enough for a Perpetual
at least exactly if you can go Bishop C5
check Queen A1 check get your queen over
to G1 and it may be unhappiness for the
world champion the bishop is out right
the bishop the bishop is alive the
bishop is alive yes and that's enough
black must be already feeling quite
hopeful about this indeed compared to
what he was facing vishy has made some
remarkable defensive resources in
particular E4 and Rook takes E4 but back
to uh louen with Maurice Ashley
Maurice yes while Magnus tries to keep
pace mvl is definitely doing his job
making sure Wesley doesn't run away with
this tournament as this position after
E7 nomachi couldn't find anything better
than Queen takes and allow his Knight to
be captured then he played this move
Queen to E6 trying to get some kind of
space in the position with on the light
squares but that did not help after
Queen C7 unfortunately this is a fork on
his bishop and King and if he dropped
his Bishop back he'd have to face this
move Knight to G2 attacking down this
line and suddenly their trades are
coming that he does not want to see for
example Rook to E2 is just answered by
this capture and then the Knight stops
anything from happening again and this
bishop is going to go lost so in this
position he had to after Queen E6 Queen
C7 he had to trade Queens but this did
not help after takes takes Knight to C4
hitting the Rook hitting the bishop
suddenly this Pawn is also being
attacked he decided to ditch this piece
but it did not help after this check
this Pawn was captured and mvl cruise to
a victory he is now in sole possession
of first as Wesley so is a point behind
him but with with Wesley so playing his
game looking very strong but no
predictions there of course he looks
like he ought to get that Victory as
well but the long game to go but the
Frenchman is acquitting himself
absolutely brilliantly in this
competition right now he's on a rooll
winning two games today and again for
the moment at least in sole possession
of first Maurice The Comeback Kid in the
case of NBL saw what he did with Paris
and he's hunting down the front runner
Wesley keeping uh the pressure on a game
that we lost track of was the game
between Vladimir and vasil uh vasel um
we had given up vasle for Deb and if one
thing we should not do is is uh U
suggest the game is over and it's not
over until it's over over and somehow
we've got into a queen and pawn endgame
Vil survived to to a point where he's
trying to get in a Perpetual check
884 bravo bravo Joy yeah Jo you can't
play in this position A7 because there's
an immediate Perpetual on the spot with
Queen G1 and queen D4 so Joy Your
Instinct was spot on A2 A4 just giving
your king a few more squares by the way
big threat Queen B5 as well as A7 did
that do it it has been played Four was
played on the board and uh right now I
think this is what vasil missed white is
completely winning because I have the A2
Square for my king very important and uh
KCK only has 20 seconds on the clock so
it's very nice uh we saw a capture but a
uh two has been played and now the
simple move King A1 King A1
King King A1 King A1 Queen D4 maybe King
A1 was played King A1 Queen D4 that's
always a good but then I can just simply
take your now I take and after Queen A4
check there's not another check in the
position lovely little dance by the
white king and A7
A8 Queen with check yes there's no
drawback to that move is there no indeed
so it looks like Vladimir karnick is won
a very uh big point we'll see but we're
going to go to Maurice uh in Len
Maurice meantime what would be a big
velopment in the tournament absolutely
would be this position being a loss if
Magnus does not survive now the engines
are giving equal for Magnus but all we
have to do is look at the clock Magnus
has 22 seconds left to his opponent's
almost four minutes and his King is the
one that is exposed as black king this
Knight is doing Yan's work protecting
Black's King against any danger so now
this king is on G3 there are lots of
moves you can play Queen D4 Queen C1
things just to bother this king and you
know Anan is looking for move that he
can play that's just not an easy obvious
quick reply meantime Magnus has to put
his defensive hat on and think what are
the best moves that could possibly
happen and what am I going to do when it
comes we know that's very hard to do
well at least for average folk Magnus
being the best player in the world he's
going to be looking very carefully at
all of Black's best looking choices
Queen D4 was in fact played and now the
move Rook back to E4 on the board and
now you see some checks are possible
down here but the queen is going to def
don't forget about this B Pawn that's
passed you take Queens off the board and
White's position sort of stops white
will have no real action to make any
pass pawns or anything this Pawn could
easily Gallop to B4 at least D5 will the
defending if this king gets in the game
it'll be a problem and queen G1 check
has been played putting pressure on
Magnus to find all the moves now this is
not looking good for the world champion
will he be able to survive Black's
Onslaught we'll see as the game ticks
down
and talking about taking down Magnus if
my clock is right is down to 22 seconds
and he just made the move King H3 a wow
what a turnaround in this this game
because Magnus had been playing
dominating chess looking really really
good and VY uh defending and now maybe
in the driver seat we have a result we
did have a result crck did win against
yes the nice A2 A4 move sealed the so to
speak and now H7
H6 uh by vishy um because the queen is
on G1 let me just point out boldly
pointing out the obvious the queen on G1
was controlling the square G6 that was
why uh um vishy thought he could essay
the move H6 and we've just had a lot of
tra we just had a trade of the H7 Pawn
for the F4 Pawn but has this helped yes
lovely move Queen E3 Queen E3 yes yes
and that is indeed a lovely move trading
off Queens followed by King G7 I believe
yes and again this Pawn on B5 the the
pawn that Maurice pointed out it's it's
definitely Galloping up the board and
all all vishy needs to do to win this
game is reposition his Bishop to the C3
Square which will support the B Pawn and
look at him go this is this is being
played Magnus I don't think you know we'
talked about Houdini like defensive
skills by these players but I don't
think Magnus uh well the problem with
Bishop C3 is that I'm going to go Rook
C4 and then I block your pawn and I go
Rook C7 next move and and that was why
vishy gave up the assault uh there and
played ni mag stilling still still
fighting hard because and Rook D1 he's
he's trying as best to I thought he
would to B to try to I don't think that
this is going to be enough for the world
champion to say the game there's now
Knight F4 check looks like a very very
attractive Square uh King G4 oops excuse
me I got something on my monitor let me
just click that away for the moment but
it's funny I've got to coordinate the B3
Pawn break with the minor pieces and
they're just a little bit off site I
probably have to go back with Knight E5
Rook A1 and reassess how best no he
liked Knight F4 did vishy Knight E2
eyeballing uh a knight C3 and to try to
escort the pawn home Rook E1 if Magnus
gets his chance to play King F5 and Rook
E7 he'll be a very happy camper um but
Knight C3 once again3 hitting a dead
Rook check King f8 you got to go behind
the pawn there's simply no choice but
has has um V given up given his opponent
he too much too much counterplay do Nile
the G Pawn combined with the King are
going to make some threat F6 but let's
see how it goes we'll we'll start with
the move King G8 for the moment if you
go King up I've got a check and if you
continue with a king I've got another
check and then so I'll have to drive
your king but
closer and closer to dra the one of your
porns will go after King E6 correct I've
got uh uh one of my two both of my pawns
pardon me are under under yes um well
again rapid chess your the clock is just
a huge huge Factor let me get caught up
on the board so I'm going to refresh
what I currently have in the game of
Magnus and bishy and by the way you just
saw that
engine thermometer just go zop
uh D we say z00 Z Christian what's going
on in this uh ending yes it seems like
uh White has found a counterplay and
right now he has enough of it uh to make
a draw this is the critical moment of
the game after King to G4 black had to
find a mechanism to stop the white Rook
from penetrating on the seventh Rank and
creating counterplay the one move he
should have played was Knight to G2 the
Knight goes to E3 and now we see all of
the squares are protected the F1
especially the A1 you cannot ENT through
there because of the A7 Pawn the A7
square is protected by the bishop on C5
and after I place my knight to E3 I'm
going to slowly slowly start pushing up
uh my B Pawn and this is just simply
going to be game over Knight on E3 is
such a powerful piece attacking the D5
Pawn controlling the rook and that would
have been just a game over unfortunately
played Knight E2 and allowed the white
to get counterplay let's go uh to Len
with
Maurice and in a game that is critical
of course because because it is
involving the leader from the last round
Wes liso who's now a point behind Vash
gra but looks like not for long in this
position suddenly it looked like black
was getting counterplay hitting the pawn
hitting the bishop on F1 white played
Queen takes Rook sacrificing against
queen queen takes and they played to
this rook and Bishop and Five Pawns
against queen king and and two pawns I
should say queen and two pawns and if we
jump ahead we now have this position on
the board this one with Rook three and
Bishop against alone Queen I remember
aronian surviving some crazy material
imbalance against Magnus Carlson
recently this one I don't think he's
going to survive and the position went
Rook Rook to after Rook takes B2 let me
just refresh my board momentarily here
and we have this position where the Rook
is stable on that D5 Square Bishop is
guarding it everything is totally
connected next stop the king bringing
that into the game this position is just
completely busted the harmony of these
forces will defeat the queen of course
the queen has plenty of checks and
plenty of tricks that are possible so
what he's going to have to look out that
nothing weird happens but it seems as
though he's in control of this game and
will Leap Frog mvl and take First Place
back thank you Maurice and we have a
result we do have a result the game
between Magnus Carlson and vishy an an
that has finished in a draw so Magnus he
escaped again and vishy the players are
pulling out Houdini like a and vishy
will look at this uh day and say what
happened uh he could easily have won
both of his game and very very jovial
Magnus Carlson realizing he dodged a
bullet in this uh crazy encounter as we
saw we did see something that happened
in the Paris event is that uh faban
Carana he was he was missing the the
wind so to speak right and in the
blitz everything turned in his favor
fortunately fortunately we could see
something very similar happen happen to
and in that game between Wesley so and
leonian I'm looking at the three uh pass
pawns King bishop and Rook uh I recall
uh winning an ending against lios porish
in an Olympiad with two with two only
two so this extra Pond uh sure feels
like it's going to be a
convincing uh technical win there and
I'm seeing that
uh Jiva who happens to be all kinds of
Pawns down in a queen and pawn endgame
uh however a draw is in the offing
because he has one incredibly pass
powerful pass Pawn as Pawn on H6 and I
just hope he doesn't make some
horrendous howler because if he avoids
the howler he will get his first draw he
will get his first point and in fact
Christian you had that game all teed up
for us no absolutely and your assessment
was uh perfectly accurate yes sir yes it
is a draw uh despite the fact that black
has two extra pawns the quality of the
Pawn on H6 is extremely important and
I'm just going to push it all the way to
H7 H7 if you don't uh check me each and
every move and once that happens only
white could hope for a win because he's
so close to promoting that pawn so uh I
see black just giving a Perpetual the
player shaking hand and jaava finally
scoring his first first half a point he
that must feel good D we applaud but I
mean it was so long and coming happened
and Wesley just won Wesley has just won
has just won so he overtakes mvl Magnus
by half a point just pointing out the
last very nice shot by
Wesley uh but let's go to Maurice with
Vladimir kic
right Vladimir kic today winning two
games uh from starting out the
tournament a bit slowly but now kind of
rounding into form but me you had a win
earlier against mvl that's a game you'll
remember for sure but it looks like you
put that behind you and now you're in a
tie for fourth place how are you feeling
about your tournament well I mean I'm
not very satisfied with my play I mean
making too many mistakes but uh okay
fighting abilities are still there it
seems indeed uh today's game once
against a player who you've been playing
for many a year what was it like playing
vasil here today well well it's always a
pleasure to play vasili because he's
played in he's playing creative chess
and he always ready to fight so but okay
the game I thought I I had a very good
opening and was very close to winning
and then I spoiled it quite a lot and
maybe at some point it was already
pretty drawish and I had little time but
I managed to drink him at the end
somehow it seems like trickery is the
word for this tournament so far a lot of
players look like they're dead and then
all of a sudden like magic rising from
the but this is a Time control yeah I
mean in Rapid chess it's pretty much
about you know at the end of the game uh
having one two minutes left that you
sort of trick your opponent that you
make some trap and so on I mean that's
pretty much about it and uh uh actually
I've been doing well against players of
who are older than me so you know youth
makes makes quite some difference here
in fact if you look at the cross table
now it's pretty much according to the
age you know so uh well of course when
you're younger it's somehow you have
more concentration it's easier for you
to play when you have little time left
so uh that's quite logical so in this
time control it's it's pretty much
decisive well you've been playing some
contentious chess we look forward to
seeing more fighting games and good luck
in your last game thank you guys thank
you Mar Vadim Vladimir youth is
fundamentally
unsound
oh and look at Yoba resetting the pieces
as he scored his first draw do you see a
little smile creeping think so it must
be what a relief not to finish for
everybody himself most especially you're
right you know I know that the the final
scores are combined between the rapid
and the blitz but still if you finish
the rapid with no points out of nine
that's got to hurt that really does
Christian your views of this incredibly
extraordinary tournament
very very exciting tournament
unpredictable tournament but as Vladimir
Kik mentioned youth is of extreme
importance and we're going to see also
the fatigue uh for the players that are
coming from Paris Wesley so Magnus
Carlson and mvl currently there are
leading but the more we enter the the
more we enter the last rounds of the
event uh the more difficult is going to
be for them to maintain their energy so
I'm looking forward to see what is going
to happen over there I'm going to see I
I'm looking forward to see what Vladimir
kramnick has in store for us because
he's on a rooll he just won his last two
games so he's definitely feeling uh
feeling very good about his form very
confident play and uh I think we're
going to see uh a lot more exciting
chess in the upcoming rounds exactly
let's go to Len where we have Maurice
with our tournament leader Wesley so
right I think it's for wi well talk
about a man on a roll we definitely have
someone who has shown when he's in the
lead you better watch out Wesley you're
playing well you drew this morning this
one was an interesting game but it seems
like you pretty much had it under
control at most of the stages of this
game yeah overall I think I'm very
pleased with the game um he took the
pawn and then I was trying to get it
back I think the he could if he play a
bit better the position would be around
equal with not much risk for him but he
tried to to create some complications
and he tried to keep his Pawn but then
he got really low on time figuring out
how to keep his pawn and he in the end
he simply blundered I mean he pled more
than once well you seem like two
different players Paris we saw you
struggling to find exactly what to do
and and being sure of yourself this time
you just seem like Wesley so yeah
hopefully I play like this every single
tournament because uh the quality of my
play here is much higher than the one in
in Paris um so obviously I I was doing
some something wrong
there but uh hopefully I can maintain
this uh but that's a good thing about
being a chess professional is there's
always another another game and even
after uh even if I played a very bad
game there there's always a chance to to
make a comeback so uh so life is not
over even after even after losing some
games oh wise words there we'll give you
a chance to rest as you have a critical
last round game for the Rapids thank you
guys we got the leader Wesley so playing
quite well and looks like he's got his
mind right as well dangerous uh
situation for the rest of the field
light doesn't end just because you lose
some games but there's our standings so
in the lead is Grand Tour champion from
2016 Wesley so he has 13 points out of
16 very impressive on his own mvl with
12 points out of 16 and uh Magnus
Carlson 10 points out of 16 all the
three uh Paris
yes uh all three of the Paris players
are actually leading the tournament I
find that remarkable I thought fatigue
was going to be a factor it's turned out
to be the opposite case Anish Gary uh
smarting that he was the one who gave up
the draw he would have like to have
joined Magnus in that third place
position with 10 points but we're very
very happy for joa uh for uh getting on
the score at Last by the way just to
Will has our great research to make a
with 20 points I believe uh still to go
in the tournament I think Wesley has
equal his score already from Paris
because it was a really poor outing
we'll just check to see if I've I on the
right and let's go to marce let's go to
Maurice with a very very happy probably
elated Jaa but I'm finished just we are
with bador jababa after a draw for him
normally not a big deal but in this
tournament things have not been going
well clearly uh what's the feeling right
now okay hard to say I'm waiting
champagne from organizer actually yes
okay what to say it's like my bed line
is finished on this draw I hope and then
tomorrow is blitz so I will try to play
well in last round now with wishi I
don't know how it will be but at least
show some normal game this is obviously
not normal for you kind of result what
what is it about this event that was so
difficult for you to adjust to okay
many uh many things effects on my play
but okay I'm not going to cry now but
okay the field is very tough so when
opponents feel that you have some
weakness they trying to like like wols
yeah they see see sick animal and they
attack yeah something like that but okay
I will try to recover in BL all right
well congratulations on stabilizing it
and we look forward to seeing you do
what you normally do playing really well
in these competitions I hope so blit
usually is better
going going better for me usually than
rapid all right with one more game to go
and then the blitz uh jababa scoring a
draw we know he's a much stronger player
than that but looks like he's getting
his mind right for the next few rounds
thank you Ma you got to love the wiip
despite the uh Seven Up losses there
whatever it's been uh organizer should
provide some champag nicely put nicely
put Christian your thoughts of again
three decisive games out of the five we
we we've been we've been spoiled there's
no other way of putting it no absolutely
we've been spoiled and one thing that
I'm very interested in is what is jobava
sunglasses what what is he using them
for we've seen jobava we've seen Wesley
but it seems like in the Len playing
hole you get natural lights so I'm not
really sure what's what's going on over
there the champagne may be coming
tonight but he still has one game left
against the former world champion vishan
and that's going to be a tough one
Magnus Carlson uh he that that was a bit
of a slum today he had a very very nice
position against vishan if he would have
converted that he would have been only I
think one point close close to Wesley so
so um he's struggling a little bit bit
but still one more game and then 18
games of of of Blitz which are going to
be uh exhilarating for sure absolutely
Christian that's uh nicely put uh about
the exhileration I'm still a little bit
mystified by the game of vishy and
Magnus because we thought Magnus was
really really really pushing it's going
to be intriguing to see where he went
wrong and we're going to have Maurice
teed up with Nigel as they reflect on
this amazing round uh over to
louen with Grandmaster Nigel short Nigel
it looks as though Wesley is just again
like you said Mr Smooth he's not caring
about anybody else his mindset more than
anything for a 23y old more than
anything his mindset is so mature so
much like the
veteran I think that's uh that's right
um but he lacks a little bit of passion
sometimes but here in a tournament like
this maybe it suits him well he's just
going one game at a time and not really
bothering about what anyone else was
doing and this was a uh a good technical
performance against L on who is an
extremely difficult player to beat so uh
he has a great opportunity to to win the
event now well there still a long way to
go mvl you have to say has been very
impressive as well as far as a dynamiss
is concerned as far as somebody who
spots tactical chances he's so
resourceful very difficult man to beat
and in the Blitz from Paris he was
tremendous so if this just stays close
he might start to rack up some points
when it comes to tomorrow's game yeah no
the the the the blitz is going to be
super exciting I the the rabbit rapid
has been great and we still got another
round so um no we've got a lot of
entertainment to come final Point Wesley
so is three points ahead of Magnus
Carlson it's hard to make up a
three-point Gap although NBL did it
against Magnus in Paris but if Magnus
doesn't get a win yeah and Wesley does
yeah making four making on four points
is going to be next to Impossible yeah
and and Magnus interestingly I I thought
he had a very good position in this uh
this last game and then suddenly
struggling struggling to to make a draw
so there's something not quite right
with the the world champion he's not
been at his best in the in the last uh
um few months anyway but he did win
Paris so yeah some it's hard to win
events back to back as well no matter
who you are but he's had several events
that he's not won and indeed well we'll
see we'll see what happens in the next
round as it's still all to play for this
last game of Rapid of course last two
points you can collect so a very
important round for all the players and
we'll be here to call the action back to
you guys in
thank
[Laughter]
you in my defense yes well in our
defense actually we have to say it is
the combined score of rapid and Blitz
just because one does well as we saw in
Paris just because one does well in
Rapid doesn't necessarily guarantee that
one is going to do well in Blitz we saw
that how MVR didn't have such a
wonderful rapit although he did I mean
he he had extraordinary blit yes so and
you have the answer to my question has
um uh Wesley equalized his Paris almost
really almost he scored 15 points in
Paris total in Paris out of I don't know
what possible but uh and uh he's on 13
points now so with 20 points still up
for GR exactly so he's definitely going
to do better than Paris fingers crossed
for him but uh yeah so we're going to
take a short break and we'll see you for
our final round of Rapid chess see you
[Music]
[Applause]
then
[Music]
[Applause]
there's a weekend vacation a one tank
trip in a nearby City you won't want to
SK St Louis
is family infity there's Museum full of
Art and super F slides upside down concr
twisty rides Houses full of magic
butterflies growing
flowers
[Music]
n
for
[Music]
w
hello and welcome back and it's round
nine of the last rapid chest and uh day
of Rapids yes and this is our third and
final uh Rapids game I tell you the
pairings just
get every every round uh you see these
fantastic matchups and there you see one
of them in fact as Ian goes up against
his former who was formerly a trainer
second the Magnus they go ahead to
Ian just coming off a tough loss and uh
Wesley so well vasil versus Wesley so uh
the Mercurial the silly you just never
know what to expect I'm looking for a
great game and then MV who's just pulled
out some extraordinary uh games he's up
against leavon who also had a setback in
the previous game vishy is going to be
looking at his uh results from today and
just shaking his head wondering what
might have been he'll be going up
against where I say it a rejuvenated
maybe he's actually not seated at the
minute exactly we've seen that
before and so we're back Joy yes we are
back and uh Christian what are you
expecting in this last round of the
Rapids well I'm uh definitely looking
forward to the game between Yan neomi
and Magnus Carlson two conflicting
Styles uh Yan very dynamic player uh he
tends to overpress at times he tends to
like sacrifice out of the blue Bluff a
little bit if I can say that Magnus
Carson whenever he receives uh those
type of gifts he tend to bask them and
uh immediately immediately strike back
with a great strategic play so that's
going to be a very interesting Clash of
styles and uh I'm definitely looking
forward to see uh what we're going to uh
get from these players thank you
yes and uh well Jova is missing uh we've
seen this earlier he he well he was in
shell shock and it was completely
excusable but uh still late at the board
uh well actually we have a
participant coming in screen there and I
it does look like
joba's right behind behind wonderful
yeah the two guys it's nice to see that
they weren't late games haven't started
so
interesting but having said that just on
time clock has ticked and vishy opening
with his favorite his career favorite uh
King Pon opening E4 now with
Jova he's not going to be playing the
tabia that everybody else in the
tournament on the elite level he likes
his filor he likes uh mixing it up we
can see Caro car very unconventional
caran exactly and Christian and we see a
French and we see a French who would
have guessed that no exactly Christian
uh any uh Games catching your fancy play
some players are moving very quickly we
do have a scotch in the game between Yan
pomos and Magnus finally I was
complaining we've seen we've seen Yan
actually being an expert in the scotch
but unfortunately we got the line after
Bishop C5 which tends to be a little bit
more drowish than the very
sharp Knight to F6 uh Knight takes C6 B
takes C6 E5 Queen E7 Queen E2 Queen D5
the other Main Line very very sharp uh
leading to unbalanced positions in which
Anything Can Happen uh Magnus is
maintaining his his strategic uh
calculated style and he did play the
move Bishop C5 I think Knight C6 was
played and we have a few more moves this
might potentially lead to an endgame
white is going to have a slight Edge but
black should be able to comfortably
equalized out of the opening
nevertheless after that we're going to
have a long game on our hands thank you
Christian I'm forceably reminded of the
uh world championship match between uh
Gary Kasparov and Nigel short in 1993
Nigel short on set there in Len as he's
talking to the audience live giving
commentary he there was certainly a lot
of scotch games and why were you uh
complaining that there wasn't a scotch
well I've had enough of I've had enough
of the Joo piano but
actually but you know these are very
unconventional positions I mean I'd like
to see play open positions you know
where play is a little bit more direct
rather than these long Maneuvers yes
we're getting tired of the uh steady
diets of um the Joko piano and Berlin uh
middle game positions and we do have a
nice imbalance game there going on
between Ian mag but over to you
Christian what else is happening well I
feel we've been spoiled a little bit and
we're complaining for nothing we had so
many decisive results we've seen very
very nice strategical play as well in
the Joko piano so uh I think we
shouldn't complain about that we do have
a different completely different
structure right now on the board uh but
uh yes in the game between Anand and
jaava we have a French and in this
position I expect white to retreat the
Knight to G B3 potentially play B3
Bishop G2 I Bishop B2 and uh slowly
slowly try to create something against
uh Black's King which will Castle short
most probably this is a very very uh
intense position uh the the center might
open up at any moment after B3 C4 and
potentially D5 at the right moment uh I
remember analyzing one of uh
vish's vious games in this in this
particular structure and he definitely
has an extensive knowledge of what he
needs to do in the in the next couple of
moves so uh I'm looking for this is this
might become explosive as well by the
way Christian take a look at the the
moves that uh were played as again uh
unconventional play
bya G7 G6 In This Very well-known Fort
Knox variation and a double fee in
shadow for black but let's go to Len and
Maurice
Ashley well a little bit of insight into
these two players you know top players
they play each other all the time so
it's no surprise if they actually become
friends and uh you have quite a few
friendships some players will hang out
with one another and these two
absolutely there's like a bromance
between them you when I watch the two of
them having breakfast together or they
go running together for example uh
exercising hanging out and just the way
they chat with each other you can tell
that these are players who really like
each other and now here they are good
friends having to play on the chess on
this in this chess tournament of course
they always have to play against each
other in all these top tournaments often
anyway and for aonian he's having a
terrible tournament he's just simply not
having a tournament up to his high
standards while here's his great friend
who's having a brilliant tournament how
do you play against each other in these
kind of situations I remember back in my
playing days I used to play against Josh
whiteskin we studied together we play
Blitz together I mean he's even the
Godfather of my son to have to play
against each other is extremely
difficult and we used to draw all the
time until his his dad said listen
people may not invite you to tournaments
if all you do is draw all the time so we
finally had to play each other that was
the hardest absolutely hardest thing to
do to have to try to take down someone
who's virtually your brother so here two
good friends playing in a very important
event we'll see how how this transpires
will they play to a quick quiet draw or
will one of the brothers have to go down
thank you Maurice I can agree with you
more Maurice uh it was extraordinary
difficult uh for myself when I'd ever
have to play one of my friends from
Seattle especially if we were on the
road in an open tournament very hard to
get that Killer Instinct against
somebody that you really respect and
you're fond of but these people are
professionals and as you were saying
they play each other on Grand chest or
um they have to take the full measure of
one another uh because so much is at
stake and they have to just put that
aside and say well I'm sorry I got to
beat you exactly you know I I can also
say that there's a nice little motto
chess is chess Life Is Life you know and
uh chess should be able to withstand you
your friendship should be able to
withstand a chess game true that so uh
yeah it was one of my roommates who T
taught me that said chess is chess Life
Is Life move on play okay that's a
philosophy we should all live by uh
Christian what do you have uh I have the
game between Nashi and Magnus Carlson in
which we see a very very interesting
Pawn structure very interesting
strategical play between the two uh the
two Lads in this position uh in general
this structure with double pawns on the
C file we get from The Exchange ruy
Lopez but in this case it came from the
scotch and black doesn't have the bishop
ER some an an asset that he gets in the
exchange Ru Lopez after Bishop B5 Bishop
takes C6 D takes C6 and so on uh but in
this position black is not doing that
bad because of this overextended Pawn on
e4 which doesn't have a potential
defense with F3 he's going to play
Knight F7 Rook E8 Knight D6 or even at
the right moment he could potentially
try a move such as G5 and try to weaken
the dark squares in the center so if
white manages to exchange all like the
Brooks the queens and get his King
active in the center then he's going to
enjoy a very nice Advantage du due to
his basically extra Pawn on the king
side uh black is going to try to keep a
little bit of major pieces on the board
and exert pressure on the eile
potentially once again weaken the dark
squares uh in the center especially that
dark Square on
E5 thank you uh Christian I'm just
looking at the game between honish G and
Vladimir kramnick and I must say I
played the English my entire chess
career and I'm never
seeing an approach that was taken by
Vladimir as he played an early Bishop B4
he very quickly gave up the dark Square
Bishop what does he have for it nothing
and then he traded queens and white had
what I thought was a very nice uh
position until it got dummied up by D6
and KN E5 trying to neutralize this
bishop on C1 looks like a Sicilian
well not really it's just an English can
fian the bishop and not that easy on
file though I see this Rook coming to B8
uh at the moment the dark Square Bishop
isn't that effective um but a very
unusual approach that I think uh
Vladimir actually uh did quite okay
W but you've got a special treat for our
viewers to talk about uh heads up shall
we say well we have a very very special
guest coming up shortly and this is none
other than World former world champion
Gary Kasparov who will be in Len with he
will be in Len with Maurice and he's
obviously he's the original brainchild
behind this idea of the grand Chester
this is his baby so indeed uh from the
days of the GMA and the grandmas World
Cup uh that he fathered and uh he's
carried it forward and also uh what Gary
in particular is very proud of is the
universal rating system that we've been
speaking about and he introduced and
there again is Anish Gary bearing down
does he have an edge with the two
Bishops looks pretty study to me I'm
going to call that one a draw at the
moment we'll see how it unfolds but
again um Magnus Carlson you know this
world changed ion it's something special
about his games we just can't get our
eyes away from him regardless of his
opponent it seems to me that you know
magnus games are the ones to watch he
plays amazing chess and right now uh
structurally speaking white has the edge
he's worse this is and let's see if he
can neutralize uh Ian's uh structural
Advantage yeah this is what I'm I'm very
fascinating by because normally plays
for these structural advantages and he
sets everything up so that he can
exchange off queens and be better in the
end game exactly and here he's can't do
the other foot he's on the other foot
well there we go that's some that's
certainly a game we're going to keep our
eye on and jooba again he's not one of
those players to uh back down from a
challenge he's got a crazy game I was
just checking in on the game between
leavon and mvl a game that's crucial for
our standings because MV in clear second
place um behind Wesley so he's playing
Black leavon ronian right
now well was just a high fluen
maneuvering yeah difficult difficult to
tell yes to me it looks very quiet but
that these positions are well known to
explode results uh possible the last
move E7 E6 that was a bit of a committal
move again it looks like a hedgehog type
of structure for the moment it White's
hoping that he will be able to put an
increased amount of pressure uh against
the half openen
defile it's a smidge I don't see this is
coming if if you you jump in with your
knight with to B5 he has D5 and I guess
he can also maneuver his Knight to E7
and get yeah perhaps D5 this well just
to follow up on whater suest say Knight
B5 D5 uh you do get an isolated que Pawn
position but having said that um it's
not like I've got the firm grip over D4
I think a lot of players will will find
this position quite acceptable uh for
the isolated Queen pong and again uh
let's take a gander at the game of our
tournament leader Wesley so he's up
against Vil ivanchuk it was this laser
variation the Queen's Gambit declined uh
very very tough to get get a white
advantage against this line it was
actually this line that vishan Nan won
the world championship against vesselin
tof winning the final game of a tied
match with the black pieces uh in
Bulgaria and the players have moved
right along to a position that looks
pretty solid I have a slight preference
for white but I don't see it as being uh
much at this time yeah I mean I also
have a PR preference for the white
position but just based on the fact that
it's some stage I will have it it would
be easier for me to get E4 and
F4 uh going yeah going but these guys
are very solid very very solid indeed
and uh Queens off things are being
neutralized where's the action well the
action is in the game of Vish and jaava
bador as expected uh we got this
position on the board we see very very
important changes in the structure white
Advanced his pawns on the queen side and
black tried to create a blockade with
this player uh this Knight on B6 very
important player in the position Pawn on
A5 Pawn on C5 the problem is the Pawn on
A5 and the pawn on C5 are going to be
very very uh weak in any potential end
game and it's going to be very difficult
to defend against all the threats so
after Rook takes d8 Queen takes d8 a
move such as Knight D3 focusing um my
attention onto your weaknesses this is
going to be very difficult for jaava and
the computers are actually enjoying wise
position quite quite heavily if you play
a move such as Queen C7 I can play
Bishop C3 focusing the attention on the
other weakness and as you can see uh
this Knight cannot defend these
weaknesses this Knight is going to have
to stay here to blockate this important
pass pawn and the bishop on B3 is
perfectly defending my weaknesses while
yours are you're having big big trouble
uh defending them and if you lose one
one my pawns are going to start rolling
and that's just going to be game over so
vatan is definitely cruising through uh
to a smooth Victory wow nice and let's
go to Maurice and Len
yes I want to Echo what you said
Christian but in this position here I
want to make this point that when I S
saw this move uh in this game it just
seemed so amazing how quickly these
players find these moves that are
paradoxical in this position Anan did
not take long at all to find what
apparently is the best move Bishop from
C2 it looks like it's on a proper
diagonal okay maybe it's biting on
granite in this position somebody like
myself I might play for H4 H5 something
a bit more aggressive in the game he
took this bishop as you mentioned
Christian and put it on B3 a move like
this a lot of players would cringe
before they play this move putting your
Bishop here it looks like a big Pawn
it's locked in and there's no space for
it on this diagonal but it perfectly
soaks up the energy of this Knight still
the Knight looks like it's the one
attacking the bishop the one defending
but the point is exactly what happened
now The Rook goes from this Square to
this one he's happy to trade off and
suddenly it's black who's going to have
to deal after Queen takes with these
weaknesses in the position this Pawn on
this Square this Pawn on this Square I
believe he played the move Bishop to C3
the engines wanted him to play Knight to
D3 but this is still the point these
weaknesses are the critical ones but
it's this move moves like that you know
a lot of times you see top Grand Masters
versus your average Grand Masters the
difference is often a question of four
or five moves in a game it's not like
they're playing every single move
they're playing a different move than
another player would play it's just
those moves that show such deep
understanding that when they play it you
go whoa and that just gives them that
energy to continue to play genius moves
incredible to watch a move like Bishop
to B3 be positionally sound and the
correct move despite what looks like
putting the bishop on an anemic Square
thank you mauce indeed that paradoxical
Bishop B3 move to be honest it wasn't on
my radar I was looking at something else
alog together but we see that
uh vishy has this just fine fine
understanding uh great judgment and he
recognized that the bishop on B3 is just
temporary
mised and it's about the pawns on A5 and
C5 really reminded me of K off that kind
of you know very
SL special player uh heads up alert uh
we got a threat going on in the game
between Ian and Magnus as the game uh
the structure has improved actually for
Ian his Pawn majority on the king side
in the center uh is um uh been
liquidated this Rook on E1 and for
beginning and and amateur players we all
love the back rank Checkmate uh the the
move Queen C5 threatens on the spot
Queen takes C4 and thanks to the back
rank Checkmate Magnus would lose a piece
so that is what Magnus is currently
facing as we turn over to Christian
Killa for more insights on the games at
Play absolutely and let's look at the
game between aronian and vashir as you
mentioned Maurice the clash between the
two brothers uh in this position after
Knight E7 immediately white spotted that
the Knight on E7 is a little bit
uncomfortable and he played the move
Bishop to A3 very powerful a forceful
move Knight to F Knight F5 Bishop takes
F5 G takes F5 and in this position after
a move such as Bishop to E7 I'm going to
force your Rook to go to E8 and then I'm
going to retreat to D6 this is going to
be very very problematic because you're
simply losing material you're forced to
go Queen A8 and after Knight to B5 I'm
not really sure what black me
but you're simply losing uh an exchange
because your Rook is not going anywhere
if you play a move such as Rook d8 I'm
going to go Knight C7 and if you don't
give me the exchange if you continue
with the with the queen dance on B8 and8
I'm simply going to take on E6 this is
game over so uh this is a forced
variation white is going to gain
material and uh this seems to be going
ER onian's way thank you Christian and I
do um uh like Joy uh the way Ian has
played it very very much he's he has uh
improved his structure he's neutralized
whatever uh Magnus wanted on the queen
side and give him one two more powerful
moves uh Maurice always calls this type
of move a post up you know you know the
Rook posts up on as great outpost on the
middle of the board back by the pawn
Rook comes to E5 the queen will uh drop
drop back with the Rook pressuring the
bishop and then Rook to E7 on the
refresh uh refreshment stall so it looks
like Magnus definitely on the back foot
and the times are 19 minutes to 15 16
minutes I think white has a very nice
slight Advantage like you say I mean I
love this idea of Rook to E5 and then
dropping the queen back and gain control
well there are advantages and there are
different advantages and this type of
advantage uh whites moves are very easy
right okay there are other advantages
where you need to play precisely here
it's just little like whites enjoying
everything that's going on I I don't see
what black is doing there's no not real
counter playing the position for Magnus
we'll keep an eye on this one and we'll
uh turn it back to Christian and ask him
where the action is once again
absolutely let's uh let's get back to
the game between vishan and jaava
because uh it is explosive and this
position we see why the computer
actually preferred the move Knight D3
get this Knight out of this diagonal and
then in the future Play Bishop C3 now if
you go Knight D7 I can simply just
exchange the Bishops and then uh simply
take on C5 let's just see it on the
board Knight takes C5 Knight takes C5
Queen to E5 I'm regaining my piece and
I'm just a pawn up instead of that white
play the move Bishop C3 and immediately
black sees the uh a potential
Counterattack initiative with a move
Knight F to D7 Queen to D2 Knight Bishop
takes E5 Bishop Bishop takes E5 and
Bishop takes G2 very nice uh little
trick now if you take on G2 I'm simply
going to play this move Queen to A8
check get out of the pin and then I'm
going to take on E5 and I'm going to
have actually a winning position because
this queen on eight is also defending
the pawn on A5 very very powerful Queen
and instead of that after Bishop G2
black white retreated with a with a
bishop on C3 still maintaining an edge
I'm going to regain my Pawn on a A5 but
the problem is this diagonal has now
opened up so counter chances for black
still in play so uh this is going to be
very very interesting to watch thank you
Christian and uh looking at the game of
leavon aronian versus MV leavon went
well mvl was dragged right down that
path that you mentioned where uh black
had to give up an exchange we've been
analyzing the position trying to find
some resources in it for
mvl we're trying to do a Houdini act
that he's been performing I like this
move Bishop before uh Joie you were
mentioning that well it's all about this
counterplay on this long diagonal and I
was trying to play this move Rook D6 you
were dropping back I was trying to plug
it up we were looking at this move E2 E3
and you also like Bishop f8 one of the
things that I'm anxious to do as white
is actually C grab your dark square B on
when you're not looking uh because I'm
thinking your king side might be a
little bit weak uh it looks to me like
an a good exchange for leavon uh but
still plenty of play and we've seen uh
very incredible uh escapes by yeah no no
I I this this position I think is a very
you know why has it under control
everything because even if the queen
does come to C6 The Rook can come to D5
and block the Diagon theal another way
so as long as you have that yes this is
just a very easy exchange uh for white
exchange up yeah okay back to you Chris
and I would like to point out the fact
that despite the fact that white has a
dominant structure because of this Pawn
majority on the on the king side his
life is still not easy because he had to
play this move B3 to control the C4
Square for Knight but unfortunately the
consequence of that is that potentially
black could could prepare play Queen D7
prepare B6 and C5 and at the right
moment play C4 and open up uh open up
the position white still has to find the
right way to create any sort of attack
on on the king side in the meantime the
problem is you cannot play H3 and G4 if
you would be able to play H3 G4 and F5
that would be almost crushing but
unfortunately uh putting this Pawn uh
Pawn majority into motion is not going
to be an easy task and in the meantime
I'm going going to try to uh put my Pawn
majority into motion on the queen side
the king might get a little bit exposed
I still believe uh White has a slight
age but this is no Cakewalk thank you
Christian but uh why did you say think
that the move B2 B3 was a necessity that
would be a move for precisely the
reasons that you were pointing out that
I would like to have avoided Rook E5 and
posting up seemed like a better choice
first let's go uh to Len and Maurice
but we have a situation where one player
is doing incredibly well and another not
so great by his standards Wesley so
right now leading the tournament vasil
ivanchuk not doing great in the event
and you would think maybe if I'm not
doing so great I should take a draw
against the tournament leader look at
this moment in the game Knight to D5
Bishop
C4 Knight C7 Bishop back to E2 Knight to
D5 hey nice little draw can go home and
say you know no problem uh no no harm no
foul I'll try Blitz tomorrow Vil said I
don't care who you are Rook D1 let's
play chess I'm going to test you some
more in this position and so Wesley did
not get the nice little calm draw he
would certainly would have liked to have
so instead he played this move G6 forced
to continue so it's interesting to see
that the world rapid Champion vasil
ivanik said I don't care what's
happening in the tournament I'm still
ready to play Fighting Chess absolutely
that is the theal we all know and love
he doesn't back down against anybody and
neither should he because he's an
extraordinary player very very gifted on
the other hand this is how Wesley has
been winning his Gams true true Wesley
has been Mr opportunist and taking
advantage as we saw Magnus overplayed
his hand and uh Wesley said thank you
very much overplayed his hand with a
blunder so everyone has been overplaying
and he's simply been playing very calmly
and taking those opportunities exactly
but uh but I think here it is very safe
it's a safe way to uh well to continue
yeah I mean no risk no harm no foul uh
at this moment G7 G6 is a move I
appreciate uh we had you had mentioned
that uh in a a previous game I believe
it was from Paris where you had
explained why it was so nice for white
in a rook of end game
yes where you you get to play Pawn to H5
well guess what Wesley Wesley
understands that concept so he played G7
G6 probably an uh anticipating an
opportunity of playing H5 himself I
still see a balanced game not too much
juice going on here
Christian we have some explosive action
in the game between uh Anand and jaava
as expected uh Anand in this position
nicely took the pawn on A5 created his
Pawn majority on the queen side but
after Knight D7 he has to make a
decision because the Knight is coming to
E5 and then jumps to F3 and then the
king is going to be in huge danger in
this position Anan play the move Queen
to D5 but unfortunately after Queen to
A5 which was immediately played now he's
having some difficult difficulties
because after King to F2 I'm simply
going to go Queen to C3 my queen
infiltrates into your position and this
this starts to uh be looking very very
dangerous for white instead of that
after Knight D7 he should have firstly
started with the move A5 waiting for the
Knight to capture on on E5 and now I'm
going to play Queen D5 I'm attacking
both your knight and your queen if you
take my Pawn on A5 I'm going to take on
E5 and I'm controlling all your checks
E1 you cannot check me A1 you cannot
check me so this is just a piece up
instead of that as I mentioned he played
Queen D5 Queen A5 is on the board King
F2 and and uh at the moment I think
jababa played Queen B4 which is still
good still infiltrating onto the dark
squares and the king is going to start
to uh feeling a little bit nauseous the
white king uh thank you uh Christian and
a game that almost going into cruise
control things have gone very very well
in my view for leavon aronian he's
actually clipped uh upon uh to go with
his exchange
but rookie to a little counter yes this
is until that's neutralized yes you
can't realize get nervous when the Rooks
get on your seventh rank this was uh the
position where we left it around these
parts uh Queen D5 please trade Queens
I'm a full exchange up mvl could not do
that and he had to give away his F5 pawn
and this is how we got our current
position any counter play is I don't
believe it but you I I've I've been
seeing miracles in this tournament
Christian so I'm not making any
predictions Miracles especially from mvl
uh the computers definitely give it to
White after a move such as Queen D3 is
going to be very difficult to defend but
I will play a move such as Queen E8 I'm
going to uh threaten to play Rook to E3
so vasher is is still having some sort
of initiative going on uh moves such as
Bishop B4 are definitely not natural and
that is what the engine is finding but
the position still has a lot of poise
left and uh I don't see black out of the
game just yet we've seen vashir pull out
some incredible Miracles throughout the
tournament is there anything wrong with
the more natural Bishop efor but okay
before this we'll go to uh Maurice in
Len an instructive situation in the game
between Anish giri and Vladimir kiik we
know that Knights and Bishops are
competing pieces and the thing is people
usually say it's three points to three
that means means nothing at the grandm
level we know that these pieces are
different from one another and because
they're so different you have to know
what the pluses are and what the minuses
are in each and every given position but
one thing we do know about Knights is
they love stable squares they need
stable squares the Bishops will dance
around Knights if the knights are
searching for squares to be on but if
you can find an outpost for your knight
and in this case maybe even two your
Knights can often shut down any Bishop
action and in this position Vladimir
crin played the move Knight to E5 here's
one Stable Square for his Knight can
never be driven away from and another
Square after this move A4 he decided to
go back to C6 F6 and Bishop G4 and the
other Knight went to D4 so these Knights
have this Square this Square on E5 they
also the B4 Square as well if necessary
Knights are very stable the Bishops are
looking for targets they need targets
just because they're fast pieces doesn't
mean that that's enough they need
concrete targets to go after and it's
not much for white to do with these
Bishops so great stability in the
position for black black might be
looking to see whether or not he can
make some hay but this B6 Pawn is
holding him down at least for the moment
so very instructive to see the the
opposing pieces nice and Bishops when
it's good and when it's not so
great thank you Maurice and we have a
result we do indeed have a result um has
been a draw between Magnus well between
iomi and Magnus Carlson so yeah both
players was the let's look as the final
this is actually the final position
black had just UND doubled his pawns
with recapture
C7 takes D6 Rook E7 and a a draw was
agreed I think the players anticipated
that there would be a The Chopping Block
we would call it all the Rooks all the
Rooks and queens get traded off and
we're in a bishop uh yes ending with
equal number of Pawns and a draw uh is a
correct result so three draws for Magnus
then it's not the most ideal result
today no I mean I think he's uh ruing
the fact that uh he spoiled the game
with vishy but then please that he
didn't spoil it too too badly to lose uh
over to you Christian is jaboa
rejuvenated jaboa absolutely rejuvenated
and it seems like vishan completely
butchered his Advantage be from uh plus
two to absolutely nothing and actually I
see him on the defensive side in this
position because of the difference
between the pieces you still have an
extra Pawn on this side but
unfortunately one of them is going to
fall either C4 either F4 and now we
let's check let's compare the pieces the
queen on B4 with the queen on D3
obviously the queen on B4 is much more
active it has a lot more targets and
targets are very very important is very
difficult for the White Queen to enter
Black's uh Black's position the Knight
the bishop look look at the difference
between the Bishops the bishop on E6
very powerful defensive and attacking
piece at the same time the bishop on D1
is just struggling to find its place the
Knight on G3 a little bit restricted you
still need a couple of moves uh to get
him into play I think what V needs to do
right now is search for the perpetual
and uh if something like this doesn't
work we actually have to be a little
difficult Knight E2 was played Knight E2
was played Knight takes C4 and queen
Queen C3 which is a nice defensive move
because you know you still have the
long-term trumps of the past BS yes
there's A4 and I'm definitely not going
to exchange the queen I'm going to run
away as fast as possible you can only
run away to one square has to be played
has to be play and Bishop C2 would just
encourage the queen to go all the way to
H1 and tickle the G Pawn so I'm not oh
we do have some we do have a queen trade
whoa we had an anticip good that's not
good no that was we hadn't anticipated
that one go ahead Christian I think I
think jaava might have missed B3 yes
jaava missed a very very difficult
tactic to see uh after Bishops in this
position C takes B4 Bishop C2 will be
played and if you play the move B3 I'm
simply going to push my own Pawn because
once you take my Bishop the C1 square is
covered by by my knight and my pawns are
very very dangerous if you play a move
such as Bishop D5 I can simply take the
pawn on B3 now this bishop is you cannot
you're unable to capture it because the
B Pawn will just run away and promote so
after Bishop after B6 uh the position is
already extremely extremely difficult
Bishop C8 has to be played but you're
simply just uh losing a pawn and these
two connected passers are going to be um
are going to be crucial uh in White's
Victory wow uh uh missing some simple
tactic there but just a second because I
was really C I was with you 100% I
didn't want to trade Queens I thought
Queen B1 was necessary
move Queen takes Pawn takes B6 he
actually played B6 right and you see joa
shaking he said he understands what
happened um it's uh the Kraken been has
been released uh two connected pass
pawns very far Advan and of for white he
couldn't take the bishop with a check
we'll go back to one moment Knight takes
check King you're still going to have to
deal with this guy and after Bishop
comes King takes and I don't think the
bishop will be able to hold back with
the support of the knight uh this Pawn
um yes and let me tell you let me tell
you something this is going to hurt much
more than all the other defeats uh
because he knows he had the better out
of Vue in this position after Queen B1
and uh he just missed a very very simple
tactics with a lot of time on the clock
uh it's not like he was in time trouble
he had a lot of time to ponder his
decision and uh he just missed the two
move tactics very unusual of such a
dynamic powerful player indeed because
you think of uh uh bad's calculating AB
ability 10 moves easy here he's missing
a two mover let's go to Maurice and
Len well there goes mvl again playing
with tricks playing to see what moves
don't lose right away and that's what
his strategy is he said just want to
keep it going keep it going and in this
time control he just seems to be a stone
cold genius look he's busted he's got
problems but he's established a bishop
on a long diagonal that's one de one
threat to deal with he's got another
Bishop that might show up on D4 if
you're not careful it's not so easy to
trade off his Rook on the seven Rank and
you can't just start grabbing anything
because if you grab something and
suddenly Queen C5 check and you're toast
you can't block on the diagonal Queen's
going to land on F2 with a thud and
you're going to get busted as mating
it's over what to do in this position
for white as black is starting to get
some action going and the most critical
thing to look at is the clock times
leavon Ron and though he's winning the
game 6 minutes to 14 minutes by his Oppo
for his opponent and now he's played the
move Rook to F1 allowing this
possibility of Queen C5 check and then
possibly this Pawn might drop off the
board still according to the engines
good for white but we know mvl doesn't
care about evaluations we saw his King
march all the way up the board against
Anan in order to save himself will he be
able to pull off yet another miracle in
this game this guy is so
impressive definitely a difficult bear
to bring down and aonian knowing his
friend is tricky is trying to make sure
none of that stuff happens but will he
play too cautiously and not be able to
reel in the win and oh maybe even lose
the game we'll see this game continues
between these FRS thank you Maurice
thank you Maurice
unlikely going to weigh in and say
unlikely there you go wow I the big big
changes have taken uh uh place in the
game between Wesley so our tournament
leader and vasil Ivan uh the world rapid
chess champion uh I thought Vil in the
position where he kind of declined the
draw so to speak was still nursing a
nice little plus exactly at these at
this moment and then you notice that
white has the defile well that really
changed very quickly as it was black
Wesley so that took over the defile and
at the moment if Wesley gets in well
there I say it the obvious Rook D2 uh
taking over the seventh
rank uh
Wesley wow uh could have uh the rapid
chess tournament tpr in the 3000 range
uh there's no way issues going on here
uh Christian for white a few moves have
been played after the move Rook D6
Bishop F1 uh with drawing the bishop all
the way to F1 defending this G2 Square
in uh anticipation of potential uh Rook
D2 and then maybe some problems around
here uh black immediately played the
move G5 to block white structures the
problem is the consequence is that
you're giving away the F5 s guys I think
we have have a result we have a result
the players have agreed to a draw in
that position uh it went Bishop F1 G5
draw agreed wow G5 uh it seems like uh
Wesley just offered the draw and vasilia
took it so thank you um because you were
about to uh say thatth the move G5 did
give up the F5 square but after for
example a move like Knight E3 which is
very natural um is's everything to play
for I see three results still uh
possible here I would for example drop
back with a Knight Knight D4 being
satisfied that well I've got play then I
can capture all I can capture the
knights yes you can and then I can
challenge you with a rook yes we can and
we have another result vvan defeated
jaava jaava definitely very
uncomfortable with his play uh he's he
must be disappointed he just felt
rejuvenated after the draw against giri
and now he just he's uh back to the
ground uh very very sad yeah that was
like you somebody said that that was
maybe one of the harshest defeats
because you just had your you got on the
scoreboard uh you got yourself into a
difficult position suddenly you're back
in it and maybe with the edge to boot
when you just make a howler that just
tosses the queen trade just tossed the
position away and vishy who could easily
have had three points out of three has
only scored well six points I should say
he only scored two um but he got the
wrong two yeah he's got this he scored
three he scored three because of
Magnus yeah he could have had six he
could have had zero he could have had
it's amazing Christian what else is
happening how's leavon doing well we
still have a very important uh game for
the standings and uh for these two
players that are competing against each
other aronian Levon versus vashir lra
aronian did find the precise moves to
keep uh the tension and Counterattack uh
the black king and in this position he
played the move Rook C to E1 entering on
the open file preparing Rook to E8 and
uh the position seems quite stable on
the king side yes queen queen H5 I can
simply just go Rook E8 Bishop to f8 and
now I'm going to withdraw this bishop
back to D2 and uh potentially not
immediately because Bishop B4 is
definitely not a threat uh because of
Queen takes H2 but it seems like White's
position is has stabilized uh and uh I
think uh he should be in the driver seat
potentially King King G2 Rook to E2
draws back uh regaining control over the
second rank this is uh crucial in in in
the positions assessment and uh aronian
is on his way to defeating vashir
nevertheless still a lot of play in the
game we've seen vashir uh pull out some
incredible Miracles well as they went
into this final n and final round of the
Rapids V here mvl was a mere Point
behind West
um Wesley already drawn means that he's
two points clear of mvl mvl needs to win
to tie for first but he would be very
satisfied if he could get out with with
a draw looking at the final position
where is it not possible to go Rook so
we are anticipating Rook check Rook
check but in yeah and then dro the
bishop Drop The Rook back to E2 yes Rook
E2 also just to deal with just to deal
with
was greedy I think the engine wanted to
go Bishop D2 to keep the rook and the
bishop on f8 pin but I agree as a human
player I'm saying this eyeballing
something wrong no no no as a human
player I'm eyeballing that rook and my
first reaction would be to try to get
rid of Queen H3 doesn't work because of
Rook takes yes and I was wondering no
and Bishop takes Pawn also doesn't work
work for the same reason right okay back
to you Christian no 100% then uh what
joi's uh is expecting I am expecting as
well from a human point of view uh
drawing back to to E2 is is is
definitely the right move to make regain
control over this important second rank
once again and uh this just looks uh
quite hopeless I have to admit after
something like Rook takes C2 Queen takes
C2 it's difficult to see how you're
going to maintain the tension as black
and uh this is uh of very very crucial
importance if you don't maintain uh the
the the problems for white I will simply
go King G2 potentially H4 G4 at the
right moment expand on the king side and
uh my king is simply just very very safe
and the black sking is actually in
trouble yeah it's all about King safety
in that uh situation I really do like
this idea King G2 and H3 but well let's
go before that but let's go to uh lven
with uh Maurice and uh an interview with
vishy
Anand we are with uh five-time world
champion vishwanathan Anan vishy today's
game somewhat slightly indicative of the
tournament overall there a lot of missed
opportunities you had before and then in
this one you missed an opportunity that
could have really cost you the full
point was I losing at some point no no
you you were never you were never losing
but I mean of course um F5 night D7
probably some Bishop C2 and
uh uh or Bishop D1 and after Knight D5
then Queen D5 which so
yeah so instead of that I could start
with something else like Bishop D1 for
instance and if he plays Knight E5 then
I go Queen D5 it should be what I'm
trying to get but um of course today was
power of the ghost this nonsense so you
went here and now this is the point
where the were saying A5 was winning and
instead you have this position where
suddenly he got counterplay uh for for
for this position and uh it it seems
like you were just a little bit off in
in your previous games when you were
playing very well and then something
would a hiccup would somehow happen in
the games well it's very nice of you to
say a little bit off I thought I was
just mental um no I think I shouldn't
bother playing chess like this there's
just no sense um and this was just
indicative of the thing I mean I thought
I was going to lose this one as well the
way it was going but then luckily I
recovered with Queen this Knight
E2
um
and because I I get this vital Pawn I
mean I I don't know if I'm um uh better
or what after Knight
A4 but he he just missed um that I can
take the queen he thought he's getting
it with check but in fact there's
nothing and the pawn pawn Queens by
itself I'm I think he should have done
this Knight D1 no
um but uh I have this
and this is probably what he missed
right so your two fast BS is stronger
than any in his
position um and then he's basically
busted I go B6 and it's uh I think he
could he could play Bishop C8 actually
instead of Bishop D5 because then I get
he gets the same thing with when Knight
comes to C5 MH and it's I it's anybody's
guess if I'm winning that or not um okay
the engine seems very
happy uh but I thought just the value of
this check and regrouping ought to be
something okay he says Knight C1 I was
going to play Knight D4 but uh he very
clever he keeps the square for the King
right so probably it's still uh winning
so you use the word mental uh you
weren't really pleased with your play
today uh yeah that's one way of putting
it
um like I said there's no point playing
chest like this that's all all right
well we know you have extremely high
standards and it's on to the blitz now
how do you clear the whole deck and and
play great
Blitz um yes I mean I'll play and see
how it goes that's all okay all right
well good luck in the rest of your games
okay thanks guys back to you thank you
re I I I I heard the those disappointing
words you know you it's no good playing
like this and again uh vishy has to hold
himself to his own incredibly lofty
standards uh but he's uh been um he's
been entertaining us let's put it that
way it's been it's been a joy to watch
these games but I think we have three
results uh Joe do have three results
we've had uh two draws and of course
vishy defeated B so still two games
going so it's aonian versus mvl and the
kick versus giri we always say one of
the most difficult things to do in chess
is to win a winning position but one of
the greatest ways of winning a one
position is to trade pieces off when
you're material ahead and and leavon has
taken a big step in that direction by
forcing the trade of queens and he's
just played this move G4 which will uh
soon get him his King out of this uh
dangerous D diagonal and he will be able
to bring up his King either to G3 or F3
nurse his extra exchange Christian how
did he manage to trade those Queens off
that wasn't an easy decision because
because of the fact that black had an
extra move after Queen E4 Queen takes E4
F takes E4 Bishop C6 white has to find
this important move Rook to C4 the only
move to preserve uh this Pawn on e4 in
case of F5 which looks like the normal
move I'm just trying to take uh the pawn
on e4 I'm now going to sacrifice my my
Rook for your Bishop D takes C6 and
after I take on F5 this is a simply
winning position because of the fact
this Pawn on B3 is controlling both
these pawns on a on A7 and C6 and while
you cannot do anything on this side I'm
simply going to start pushing my pawns
on the king side very very important uh
uh calculation by aronian and uh
obviously mvl kept as many pieces on the
board as possible and after Rook C4 he
played the move King G6 he doesn't want
to allow simplifications another
psychological aspect of of playing in a
lost position you don't want to allow
simplifications but after G4 King G3 as
you were mentioning Yer White is simply
dominating and he should be able to
convert quite handily well the players
are blitzing right let's keep an eye
this is the upto-date
position Joy a minute versus a minute
versus eight n nine minutes wow mvl play
quick play quickly and badly if you get
this uh position but the two Bishops not
always easy to overcome even when uh
there's not even a pawn to be had like
this King E3 by the way uh The Rook it's
it its ability to get in the game as we
saw in the game of Magnus right uh you
know Magnus was trying to activate his
Rook against vish's two minor pieces he
succeeded and broke through uh this is
what uh leavon is looking for is a way
of getting his rook in black skin
exactly the problem is he only has one
minute left on the clock well this is
another thing you know if normally with
the increment you could play a few quick
moves build up some time figure out the
winning plan but uh here here it's not
that easy I have to I'm just wondering
where you just go
Bishop Bishop D6 and yes try try to find
your abely like uh uh this move uh the
king king
E6 um H I have to admit King D4 looks a
bit uh dangerous for strange uh for me
as well I thought the Rook was going to
actually slip across over to the G
uh to you know dream of getting in on
again into Black's camp but I do like
Leon Play Because Rook G2 you know you
target the H Pawn well let me play the
devil well I don't want why do I have to
defend M only he can produce the
Miracles okay I'm going to throw out a
check okay King Retreat to defend the B
okay check King look at me go aren't you
impressed yeah where are you going to
the king I'm Sid stepping C3 okay I'll
just draw back so we cannot see your
moves oh I'm sorry we you don't have my
okay we will we will uh keep an eye then
on the webcam the players as what were
you uh what were you considering in this
position after G2 I I don't want to tell
you Bishop B6 right yes you were trying
to uh throw a check in King to D3 and
another one and another check and I'm
going to go let's say here yes and this
is where I gave it
up rook G5 Rook G6 it seems like the
rookies
penetrating and it's going to be very
difficult to keep all your pawns
defended exactly and what was the other
game that was actually on giri versus
karnick I see though we haven't really
kept an eye on that one because this one
is so crucial for our tournament
standings and again
leavon uh under pressure pressure of the
taking clock that's a nice this is a
nice play now that
this but I think it doesn't matter just
like just King well you want to play
King D4 but after for example Bishop d8
Rook G6 check King F5 uh they're still
tricky
so no king king Bishop d8 G by the way
keep an eye on the clock it does tick
fast okay 49 seconds quickly played um
King C3 again Bishop E5 easy transition
for white you would trade Bishops play
Rook G5 check play Rook takes H5 and win
very very easily hence we see this move
Bishop E5 trying to keep it as complex
as
possible uh Christian jump in yes Bishop
H4 Rook to Rook to G7 um I I I'm failing
to see a Black's counter play anymore uh
once again it's it's still far from over
because of the time Factor only 27
seconds as we see the clock right now
for aronian and um you know there's
still tricks in the position if you put
your Rook on G6 I can potentially play
uh King G6 King E King F5 King E4 uh
support my Pawn I this is not over and
the just found a very crafty move this
move Bishop F2 uh supporting the uh
opport Unity of pushing his D4 Pawn
forward and um it's not that easy still
I like what leavon has done so far
certainly he hasn't spoiled it but mvl
is going well he's just holding he's
holding the Fortress right you know so
H4 is coming and as long as the king
doesn't penetrate then King
D2 the material is very limited so if I
manage to exchange a few pawns then
Bishop E3 is a huge threat uh black
could not afford the trade of the dark
Square Bishops but now Rook H5 as
Christian mentioned in the previous very
who no Rook to G6 was played after
Bishop C5 I think uh but uh yeah King
wait King F5 Rook F6 King E4 what is
it's starting to look very dangerous for
Le whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa uh he
just helped activate Black's King oh my
gosh are we going to see another
mirac I look at the clock time the clock
time is the Leon
has seconds where leavon problems lie I
mean he's still winning but how is he
winning the path is getting narrower and
narrower so after H6 Bishop H6 he's
eyeballing the opportunity playing
Bishop f8 but notice that the bishop on
B5 is also covering the promotion Square
so uh
E7 um do cause a panic well we got to go
Bishop B4 check right or King E5 or King
E5 runs into Bishop
G7 and the now and now potentially and
he's played instead Bishop E7 Bishop
E7 okay he's trying to wrong foot The
Rook I'm not exactly sure
Rook
and the moves are coming Fast and
Furious as the clock is again a key
factor uh MBL with a full six
minutes I guess King D5 or King E5 King
D5 very good move yeah King E5 oh I
think and still I mean um leavon is not
not having an easy go of this technical
conversion but Rook F4 okay finally he
can get rid of some of Black's Pawns in
the position especially that dangerous
D4 pawn and
now it's easier still work much much
much easier still work now he'll have to
round off the for for a moment there
when black played the move King E4 I I
had a sudden fear that you know MBL
could have actually been better but that
was not the case and
leavon had the advantage and it's all
about making the time for but the
problem is that I also have the idea of
playing Bishop E5 H3 Bishop F1 Bishop
G2 and that could potentially lead to
some unpleasant complications for uh for
white okay I definitely would not want
to put the pawn on H3 precisely for the
reason you just cited uh I the pawn on
H3 would become a target for the light
Bishop so lon's move Rook F2 excellent
move in order to play Bishop F4 and keep
the pawn nicely uh tucked away we do
have a
result and a draw has been agreed
between Anish and um Vladimir I think
Anish is going to be very pleased with
the score he's racked up in the Rapids
uh he I think it was the first day he
was 50% but after the first
day no losses and a couple wins in there
only had that very unfortunate loss
against Ian nomachi in the in the first
day and after could easily have won yes
he should have won really he'll be
kicking himself or not winning this one
well this is not going to be an easy
conversion let's head back to the uh
aronian uh game if I manage to exchange
the A and B pawns yes then that's going
to be very very difficult to make any
progress for white I'm going to put my
Pawn on H3 Bishop on G2 or Bishop
somewhere defending that pawn on H
and after that is just going to be
extremely difficult to make any progress
well I would I would suggest the black
need well white need to start exchange
trying to exchange off a set of Bishops
if I can manage that he would definitely
be loving that opportunity and as
Christian says uh the best way of
resistance is to put the pawn on H3
which would make that pawn
virtually uh Untouchable Untouchable uh
yeah you can't capture it without
dropping an
exchange and you're right um but okay
Christian I
wow well let's uh let's hold on this
thought but we have Maurice in Len with
a very special guest show you we've been
waiting for
it well as the bells are tolling here in
louan uh at top of the 6:00 hour we we
have Gary Kasparov former world champion
one of the greatest players of all time
Gary you're sitting with some amusement
watching this game I'm going to bring
you in as a commentator what do you
think are white chances of winning it
looks like he's definitely up in
exchange and winning chances but mvl has
been so slippery and it's only 15
seconds on the clock for aronian look
I'm surprised the game was still on yeah
when I left my H room just just heading
for here I thought the game would be
over very quickly because nvl was
completely lost and the r had a very
good game uh but it's still the game
still goes on I I don't know I still
think white white should probably win
but you point out at the clock it's just
15 seconds left and it's quite difficult
because two Bishops they're quite tricky
they can create impenetrable barrier so
it was as long as two Bishops on the
board and the clock is on mville side uh
I think it's maybe maybe the game will
will end up uh will end up differently
it's a so I still think white white
white r but enville was so uh resilient
in in in in in in in these uh
tournaments uh today just see the game
was Anon uh um it's just you
know game game with crnic so it's this
is it's I don't know whether it's pure
luck or maybe you know he's being some
compensated for his for his resilience
it's but the game still the game still
goes on and uh um again last one the
engines don't like at all somehow and he
has found this move King D6 penetrating
into now now it's over now it's over
because it's just it's the that's it
it's the so he actually made the last
last blunder oh those still it's the
again it's this aronian should should
find some you know some now Bishop C5
check he's back in
business back in business yeah so that's
it two two Bishops two Bishops I can
remind Nel I think I saved the game that
second game in our world championship
match had rook and Bishop I think we
have two have two Bishops so was somehow
again but as long as two Bishops are
there okay I one one more Pawn probably
as a comp compensation but with two
Bishops you always safe because they
they create they create a lot of mess
well a mess indeed this kind of Chess
rapid chess you played many times what's
the challenge here for for someone in
this well now looks now it looks really
bad
Bish at all that's it he just he just L
the no okay let's play this fast with
all those chances for n should he have
played this quickly given that he had 5
minutes plus on the clock was he trying
to Blitz you know he did have 10 seconds
I think it's I think it's it's it yeah
okay the game was over yes no way to
deal look it's easy to to to give advice
standing here you know it's the it's
it's you always tempted you know there's
two bullets because you have so much
time upon a little time but you should
remember it's it's a delay there's a 10
seconds delay so uh unless you create
some problems uh the player of horon uh
uh caliber will play also very quickly
so you again being um of a smart
Observer here downstairs just telling
them what it you should do upstairs I
would say that you rather think uh maybe
even spend a minute uh by just you
creating some kind of uneasiness for for
the opponent
and thinking about a plan so what can I
do so what is the best defense line uh
and you have to come up with some
quality moves to make sure that Aron
will start spending uh uh uh his his
precious seconds because again as long
as it's the moves are easy for him so 15
seconds is it's an illusion for the
public but it means he has 10 seconds to
to complete each move and it's more than
enough for for for player or R's class
absolutely uh now now that this is over
with the standings for the day we see
mvl still in second place still in a
good situation know two points by the
math behind Wesley so what's your
evaluation I want to get your feel for
two other players in the tournament
first of all Magnus Carlson the way he's
played this event naturally he dominated
the Rapids in Paris and then he had a
fall off when then he was able to win
what do you feel about his play and
missing it look I U I think for Magnus
the biggest problem is huge expectations
and uh he he lives he lives under uh the
moment he plays he believes rightly so
that people want him to win and that's
why we we could see same same uh
slippery roads as as in game was saw the
game was equal dead draw and mag was
pushed pushed pushed and again if you do
it if you if you do it uh uh uh re so
recklessly I heated against Wesley so
you end up with a disaster and by the
way I think that's the game the game
served Wesley because he gained
confidence that he he didn't he didn't
have in Paris and uh that's that's the
game probably decided the the fate of
the whole tournament well the fate of at
least the rapid por no rapid portion of
the tournament um Magnus is behind but
Magnus is a phenomenal police player uh
yeah we saw mvl performing extraordinary
in Paris so that's why definitely we're
going to see some you know some exciting
exciting uh um bleed section of the
tournament Wesley is way ahead but but
in Blitz both Magnus and ve especially
Magnus they I would I would take them
against Wesley so I don't know what what
what what will happen but Wesley plays
well so that's very important he
definitely regained confidence that he
totally lost in Paris and uh if he keeps
his composure for for Blitz it's a it's
the two points Advantage is is is is
quite a serious serious start uh um
start for bleed though I would say that
Magnus nil will definitely try to uh
catch up and and and um especially
Magnus and will um uh liquidate his
deficit well and we saw in in Paris that
even Magnus had this Edge and wasn't
able to keep it against mvl who was I
think three points but mag lost three
games in the row I mean I can I can I
can hardly recall any other tournament
when those three games in the row but
again huge pressure huge pressure so
we'll see what happens tomorrow um me
Magnus is psychologically important it's
not going to uh to be the end of the
world for him if he doesn't win this
tournament because he already won one
but psychologically it's important
because in Paris he was so close winning
uh um tournament with clear first he
ended up tying and he won the tie break
he showed his Champions character but
still never loses exactly but you know
it's still it's it's it's it's still
somehow unpleasant that he he doesn't
dominate the field let's remember last
last uh uh year um grest tour he he he
because of the world championship match
he couldn't take place in all
tournaments so he was a wild card and he
was second in Paris but first in in in
in in Len and he had I think 23 points
in total and and he was way ahead would
have easily won the Tour absolutely you
would easily won the Tour if you would
played now this year we'll see what
happens because if MV does fairly well
tomorrow uh and Wesley keeps his um um
uh keep his um strengths I'm not sure
man have the same the same they yeah
though of course I think I expect him to
to to to be the lead after after uh
living we know you're here to do a
speech at the University talking about
your new book tell us uh a little
Prelude to what's going to happen oh um
it's a book about uh uh my it's it has
three components it's it's my uh
personal story um of uh playing the
machines uh uh fighting chess chess PL
computers the famous match with ibmd
blue it's also the history of human
machine relations and uh it's my
take uh for the future so what will
happen uh with us while artificial
intelligence um keeps growing and and
taking more ground and uh AI is is is
considered by many as a threat for for
Humanity and I have uh fairly positive
uh
um forecast for the future and those
those datas I will I will share with the
audience tonight well I know you did
some insights a Ted speaker as well the
book is called Deep thinking deep
thinking yes and uh definitely want to
pick it up when when machine
intelligence ends and human creativity
begins there it goes Gary always a
pleasure to talk to you former world
champion Gary Kasparov he knows a thing
or two about being at the top and the
pressure guys back to you thank you so
much Maurice yes so what's your take
when will be the first marriage between
human and robot
first that's what everybody wants to
know after deep thinking yeah well uh
David lovey said 2050 but let's take a
look at our tournament standings after
the rapid uh chess portion of the event
is over the well after nine games of
Rapid it is Grand Tour chess champion Wy
so from 2016 who is in the lead with 14
points out of 18 in second place even
after his defeat is still MBL with a 12
point out of 18 and uh the third place
we have world champion Magnus Caron 11
points out of so he's not far far behind
lurking close behind and uh on Fourth
Place Anish giri with 10 points out of
18 and then we have a big tie from fifth
place with Ian Nomi Vladimir KCK and
Leon aronian nine points so it's it's
still quite tight at the top and Ian is
also one of those players who has a very
very big Blitz reputation so we it's all
about for as Wesley so has said
Christian what a around what a day your
thoughts of this extraordinary uh
tournament in Len well absolutely Wesley
so is a completely different man and I'm
not expecting to do as poorly as he did
in the Paris Blitz event where he scored
I think only two points or two points
and a half out of 19 games hu very very
bad result uh he's in the lead he has a
boost of confidence after defeating the
world champion and uh he's definitely
going to try to take this home uh the
world champion has some ground to catch
up I think he's uh two points behind the
leader and uh but tomorrow is you know
it's a clean slate we're going to see
who's going to bring their aame uh to to
to the playing hold Yan piai very very
important unpredictable player in Blitz
he is a monster you can see how fast and
how confident he plays in the rapid
imagine what will bring to the table in
the blitz uh section so it's going to be
a very very exciting two days and
there'll be playing nine rounds of Blitz
with a 5 minute and 3 second uh delay
right so uh we'll just head over to
Maurice who has an interview with Wesley
so with the 2016 grandchester champion
and the current leader here in louan
Wesley so Wesley congratulations on
finishing this phase I know you didn't
Winn the tournament you just yeah won
the rapid St took care of the rapid
stage still a lot to go so maybe it
doesn't mean anything but it certainly
means a lot to be leading after this
phase yeah definitely I'm very pleased
to win the the rapid section because uh
here in Rapid we don't I mean compared
to Blitz we don't just play for time we
also play on the position so I'm very
very CL of this fight you're two points
ahead of the field as we go into the
blitz yeah
a good lead but certainly not a secure
one no yeah two points is not really
anything I mean if I lose couple of
games tomorrow then that's it then I
have to start all over again so I have
to make sure uh that I'm in on top form
tomorrow to and I that I keep up that I
keep it up you know still two more days
to go two more days lots of games what
do you do to stay in top form as you've
done so far you look pretty much
Untouchable in this phase yeah well I
thank you yeah well uh first of all it's
hard to to say exactly the necessary
things to do to arve in that form I mean
before before this rapid tournament I
couldn't have guessed how I will do I
mean could have gone either way but uh I
think once we're in a tournament or once
I'm in a
tournament I for the most part I tend to
stay very focused on the game I don't uh
go out at night go party and try to get
a good why you looking at me
what no there are other people too
maybe but for for the part yeah just
lots
of also to have some sort of straty
strategy to know once I arrive on the
board what I'm going to do exactly what
my opening is and uh what I'm hoping for
in in the game against a specific open
opponent you looking at the standings
it's it's Paris Paris Paris right the
three of you played in Paris and now the
three of you are at the top mvl and
Magnus it looks like maybe the secret is
to I mean ma Maxim and Magnus uh it
looks like the secret maybe is to is to
play as much as possible get into form
is is it good that you guys are doing
the back to back as opposed to other the
players who did Paris but only do the
Louis instead
speically requested that I do PES in
Belgium instead of PES in St Louis what
my other American counterparts Fabiana
and hik did um I think it's just getting
used to the time control you know
we we play one or two fast chess each
year and uh just the different time
control every single tournament you know
it kind of It kind of uh changed just
our our Rhythm a little bit so we need
time to get used to it
um said big
Bo to this the one imp Paris and to get
used to you know to learn from our
mistakes and also to get used to the to
the delay time control because for
example if I if I'm correct uh this is
scr Nick's first
delay tournament so it I think it takes
some time to to get used to because for
the most part we're classical Chesters
our main focus is playing uh classical
chest because still that's the where the
most tournament which most tournament
holds but that take some time get used
so I'm very excited for for tomorrow
because uh I've never really won of this
tournament my career and
uh you know my my this are just uh below
average so hopefully more things will be
be different but I definitely have the
comfor absolutely well looks like the
strategy has worked to play back to back
congratulations on your results so far
and
for Grandmaster Wesley so showing his
class here in this event they will be
chasing him down for sure but the way
he's playing he's going to be a tough
horse to catch thank you Maurice
apologies for for the little video H up
audio that it's a long way to moving
from St Louis is true all right we'll
have to have share some final thoughts
as we get ready for a blitz chess
weekend
Christian share well the action is going
to be fast furious and very very
exciting so uh I'm definitely looking uh
looking forward to waking up at 5:00
a.m. tomorrow and uh getting all excited
about the blitz event which is going to
be thrilling for sure thank you
Christian yes and JY uh uh well are you
looking get up at 5:00 in the morning
you know just to see yes of course you
know it's 18 18 games of Blitz and as we
saw in Paris it was speed it was tactics
it was everything so I'm absolutely
looking forward to it and I I think okay
wle so is the leader now but I'm not
really sure whether it was his weakest
portion this is the what I'm slightly
concerned about it was his weakest part
of the game in in Paris he he scored
very badly and it was a time it was it
wasn't to do with his form such it was
the time issue that he was struggling to
manage and Magnus too yeah but I think
confidence had so much to do with that
poor outing and uh let's go to Len with
Nigel short and marce
Ashley and we're with Grandmaster Nigel
short after a long day but certainly a
fruitful one we've seen West so as you
predicted sir playing very well indeed
and again for a 23y old he's got such a
level head maybe he's not the the killer
assassin Gary casparo for example but
he's just wise Beyond his years he's
very sensible I would say he doesn't
take undue risks and uh he plays with a
very steady hand and in this tournament
that has been sufficient indeed it has
what do you think are his chances now in
the blitz he's got to face some serious
Lightning
Fast MBL for sure is incredibly as we
know and so slippery as well and nothing
else needs to said it is uh very much a
matter of form much more so even than
rapid chess so it can be one of those
things that you wake up and you're a
little bit groggy and
uh it's not there at your fingertips so
uh I think you you you see after the
first uh two or three games who's got uh
who's
hot right indeed well we'll be bringing
you thetion here from Lin cuz it's
getting hot in here we're loving it guys
see you tomorrow thank you than thank
you Maurice wow well 18 games of Blitz
to go 18 points yes 18 points you play
each player it's kind of a double round
robin so you have it in your mind you're
going to play black and white with
Magnus you're going to have to play
black and white with NBL but it is about
who's going to be in form and I think
Nigel made a very Salient point that in
Blitz you feel it after just two or
three games you get your form and you
know what to expect from yourself right
you can also play you know you get the
feel for the positions and you get the
feel for how things are working with
your your sharp or not but one thing I
just thought of just now the guys who
just po who just jumped into L they
would have seen the others in action
right and they can start prepar they
would have prepared openings so to speak
me well the the guys from
Paris
well no time for Preparation there so
well we've got a lot forward uh to as we
move to the blitz portion of our
tournament we'll be here tomorrow same
time same channel tune in for nine games
of Blitz at the louen Grand chest tour
second leg Edition it will be absolutely
exciting join us
[Music]
then